Welcome to Google Cloud Next 20
Day 3 keynote
Welcome back to Google Cloud
Next 20  17 in San Francisco  .
I'm Timothy Jordan  .  A
developer advocate and I'm I'm
with Google education and one of
the host      hosts for the G
Suite show  .  This is the last
day of Google Cloud Next  .
What a week it's been  .  It's
dedicated to deep dives on --
about how they are leverage
leveraging Cloud  .
Just as action packed and
yesterday  .  We have put
together some of our favorite
moment        moments for you to
enjoy  .  And here they are
Good morning  .  Welcome to the
second day of next  .  It's
probably the largest global
network today  .  Between 25 and
40 percent of global Internet
user traffic  .  We put a
security chip on all our new
machine  , to serve as a basis
of trust for that machine  's
identity  .  It's so small that
I'm wear      wearing one on my
earring A G Suite  , we're
obsessed with the idea that
computer          computers
should constant
constantly raise the
bar on what can get done with
the mundane  .  So that our user
users  , your employee
employees  , have more
and more time to focus on doing
creative work Cloud enable
enables enknow vai
vaitive business model
models  .  New ways of you
creating and changing your
business that you wouldn't have
been able to do before is a
white board in the Cloud  , in
the meeting room and beyond your
meeting room      rooms  .
Just pick up the stylus  , you
start think       thinking  ,
and communicating and work
working with your team do
they come to GCP  ?  They want
the world  's best security  .
They the core promise to
developer           developers
still remaip        remaips the
same  .  Bring your code and
Google will handle everything
else  .  So that was day two  .
Drea  , you also had a chance
to talk with someone about
Stackdriver  , right  ?  I sure
do  .  I talk      talked with
Amir  , a product manager on
monitor         monitoring  ,
logging and diagnostic
diagnostics for the
Cloud  .  I'm here with Amir  ,
who is lead      leading a
session learn       learning
best practice          practices
called the thin line between
inform        informing and
everyone will have access to it
over the next couple of day
days  .  also excited to be
here  .  So I'm a product
manager on Google Cloud platform
and I focus on the Stackdriver
Services Suite  .  Stackdriver
is all about monitor
monitoring  , logging
and diagnostic
diagnostics for our
user      users that are running
their application
applications on
Cloud services  .  And I'm based
here in Mountainview  .  Oh  ,
nice  .  Me  , too  .  So when
it come      comes to  , as we
mentioned the topic of the
session  , learn       learning
best practice          practices
, but learn       learning
more about Stackdriver  , why is
this important when we're think
thinking about the Cloud
?  the years  , we worked with
a lot of our user      users  ,
making sure that they have
everything set up caekt
caektly and they are
correct         correctly
monitor         monitoring their
application
applications  .  And
we realize that alert
alerting is the hard
hardest part to get right
.  And so we want      wanted
to use this ability to use the
things we learn       learned
with stack monitor and to help
our user      users and user
users of other Cloud
platform provider
providers get alert
alerting right  .  We come
across case where user
users alert too often or
they don't alert on the right
things  .  So we want to share
our insights  .  How does
Stackdriver fit into all of that
?  Stackdriver is our service
that allow       allows user
users to alert on things
that they run in the Cloud  .
But the session is also
applicable to users of other
either competing services  , or
free services  , Open Source  .
So it's really applicable to
anyone that is running
production services in the Cloud
, and they want to make sure
that their user      users are
presented with sort of their
best foot forward  .  Right  .
And so in addition to lead
leading some of the session
sessions on that  , I
guess for you  , what are you
most excited about when it come
comes to the future of the
Cloud and when it come
comes to the spic products
that you're work      working on
?   .  So with Stackdriver and
general         generally in
Cloud  , I'm really excited to
see that the focus is shift
shifting from maintenance
, and that kind of overhead  ,
to really innovate oh on
innovation  , so user      users
today have better tool
tools that are -- it's
easier to set up and require
very low overhead and so they
can focus their efforts  ,
instead of on main taping  , on
innovate          innovating  .
And so that leads to better
application
applications  , and
better services  , and more
exciting things that we see out
there  .  Well  , thanks for
join      joining us today and
giving us a sneak peek into your
session         sessions that
you'll do at  :      Google
Cloud Next  .  We will have a
chance to check it out on
YouTube  .  Of course Tim knee
and I spent more time in the
Cloud showcase  .  Like
yesterday  , we thought it would
be cool if we brought you along
as well  .  Here we are at the
Jamboard  , and I'm stand
standing with Ishwarya  ,
could you tell the live stream
view      viewers what you do at
Google  ?  I'm a product
manager on the Jamboard team  .
For those few people out there
that don't yet know what a
Jamboard is  , what is it  ?
Jamboard is a fun digital
collaborative white board  .
Everyone love      loves how it
look      looks  , it look
looks great in a room of
the it's the first thing people
walk to  .  It's fun to write on
it  .  It's a great
collaboration device for people
who are work      working in
remote office        offices  .
You could be in New York and I
could be in London  .  Let's say
you are on a Jamboard  , I
could pull up my tablet and we
could  :  Rate together  ,
sketch  , just anything that you
would do on a normal while
board  , you can do the Jamboard
, but instead of taking a
picture and email       emailing
it to me  , we could do it real
time and you could just send it
to me and then you can add me
.  That's awesome  .  We spend
a lot of time on VC  , All the
time  .  And there  's
whiteboards behind us  , you
sketch  , you have to turn the
camera  .  Or take a picture and
send it over to people  .  It
adds so much overhead to the
collaborative overhead  .  What
are some of the other tool cool
things  , we can pop do in and
do drain storm       storming on
.  Let's say we want to talk
about do you go dog     dogs
during a meeting  .  Once the I
am maming        mamings show up
, you can pull them out  .
And then chain them up  .  And
then if you want to delete  ,
just slide them down  .  So that
is something really cool  .
And another thing that I love is
the Web search  .  So anything
that you would search on like
Google  .Com  , you can just
search in here  .  Let's say I
want to go to New York City and
I just want to pull up a map of
Manhattan  .  This will take a
bit of time  .  You can just
crop out the image and pull it
into your jam  , write on it  ,
market place              market
places  , star place
places  , send the file to
your friends  , you can mark
different place       places at
the same time  .  Like a
doughnut place and then pull an
image of doughnuts from that
place  .  Another this thing
that is awesome is the
handwriting recognition  .  Not
every one has amazing
handwriting like me  .  So for
people like those  ...
That was really cool  .  And
then you can also theet it  .
Thank you for the quick tour of
the Jamboard  .  I'm excited to
standard jamming  .  This is the
meet the experts area  .  Where
developer           developers
get to ask experts from Google
their question  , and work on
solutions together  .  I'll join
Drea over here who found some
of the Firebase crew and we will
talk about something that just
launch        launched  .  Hay
y'all  , how are you doing  ?
This is Doug  , he will tell us
about something that just launch
launched  .  we just
announced Google Cloud function
functions for Firebase
, it let's developer
developers wrote
write back in code in
response to events in their
Firebase project         project
I'm excited about this  .  Tell
us what developer problem
problems does this solve
?  found that developer
developers really
don't want to create their own
server        servers ring
maintain them  , upgrade them
and deploy to them  .  So what
they would rather do is just
code deploy it to Google service
and let go of all the
administrivia and it's a great
tool that developer
developers use to
build the back ends for the
mobile app     apps  .  How do
developer           developers
get started  ?  Going to
Firebase.Google.Com  .  Find the
function          functions
feature there  , and you can get
on with that right away  .
Cool stuff  .  thavshs  .  We
will catch you soon  .  Here we
are in the G Suite area  .  Tell
us a bit about what is going on
Wes  .  everybody  , how are
you doing  ?  Doing great  .
One of the things that is cool
about what      what offer
offers  , it's a little
something for people to build
things  , to solve problem
problems in their
enterprise  .        Exactly  .
We have developer tool
tools for people who are
full time developer
developers  .  But we
have stuff where  , if you're
try     trying to get something
done  , try     trying to build
an app to put together a report
.  You don't have to be a
hardcore software engineer  .
We have a cool product called
App Maker  .  It's a low code
development environment  , where
you go from idea to app in day
days  , not months  .  And
you don't need an engineer
engineering resource  ,
you can build a simple simI  ,
add the correct
correcttors and all of a
sudden you are done and gone  .
If you want to do more work  ,
App Maker run     runs on top
of App Script  , it gives you
access and your app     apps
access to data in Google G Suite
, you can access other Google
services  , but you can make
external call      calls to like
an outside relation
relational database  .
For the hardcore software
developer  , we have the rest
API  s  , you can integrate kal
enlar       enlars  , Sheets  ,
and Slides into your application
applications  .  So
there also has been a lot of G
Suite announce
announcements and
product updates  .  Talk to us
about some of your favorites or
highlights from those  .
announced that Team Drives is
general         generally
available  .  It's really
excited         exciting  .  Now
if employee          employees
move or change joshs  , you
don't have to worry about who do
ee reassign the owner
ownership to  ?
Everything is opened by the
organization  .  Team Drives is
accessible  .  So your autopsies
can integrate request Team
Drives  .  The other thing was
Gmail ad ons  , you can
integrate your mini app and have
it built into Gmail so they can
access your app without having
to leave Gmail  .  It's like
braeshing           braeshinging
the cycle of I'm work
working in Gmail  , I have
to pop out  , go  tory ee app
and get back  Too many click
clicks  .  Wes wos and
your context is crazy  .  So if
you can build in a bit of your
app within Gmail  , that goes
for a better seam less user
experience  .  Last question  ,
if you want to get start
started on this  , why do
they go  ?
Developers.Google.Com  .  You
can find App Script  , App Maker
, Gmail add-ons  , Google
drive and Team Drives  .  We're
here at the Cloud span
spanner booth with Selena
.  Tell us about what you do  ?
Product market
marketing for GCP
database          databases  .
We are either at the span
spanner booth and this is
something that I'm particular
particularly excited
about  .  Yes  , you are  .  I
am  .  I talk      talked a lot
about it  .  But I've been
frustrate bid having to choose
between horizontal scaling and
transtransactional consistency
.  But I don't have to choose
with span      spanner  .  You
don't have to khoods and having
a relational database that
scales Horton stall
stallly and keeps the
scale is huge  .  It's also in
the Cloud  , so it's fully
managed  .  That makes it a lot
more easy to implement  .  Where
do we learn more about it  ?
Cloud.Google.Com/Spanner
Cloud.Google.Com/Spanner  .
Well  , Drea  , it's almost time
for the end of our preshow  .
Is it already  ?  Of course,
that means it's almost time for
the final keynote  .  Today  's
keynote has an awesome line up
dedicated to Open Source and
cloud-native architecture the  .
We will look at Kubernetes and
Tensorflow  .  Then we will
here from receiver receiver
receiver on the history and
value of free occupy source ware
for infrastructure  .  Jeff
dean will do a deep dive into
Tensorflow  .  And then Sam will
talk about build       building
an open Cloud  .  We will hear
from start up    ups and the
venture capital community about
how they are leveraging
they areing     inged
Cloud to build the next wave of
products and services  .
Alison Wagonfeld will close out
the keynote  .  Let's get do to
it  .  Connect with us online  .
Our Twitter handle
handles are on your
screen  .  Enjoy the show and we
will see you next time  .
...
Speaker: LADIES AND GENTLEMEN,
OUR PROGRAM WILL BEGIN SHORTLY.
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS AND
SILENCE ALL MOBILE DEVICES.
THANK YOU.
[ MUSIC ]
Speaker: LADIES AND GENTLEMEN,
OUR PROGRAM IS ABOUT TO START.
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS.
[ MUSIC ]
Speaker: LADIES AND GENTLEMEN,
PLEASE WELCOME GOOGLE'S VICE
PRESIDENT OF PRODUCT MANAGEMENT,
DEVELOPER AND COMPUTE PLATFORMS
, SAM RAMJI.
[ APPLAUSE ]
Sam Ramji: GOOD MORNING.  I
CAN'T TELL YOU HOW THRILLED WE
ARE THAT YOU'RE ALL HERE TODAY.
I HOPE YOU'VE HAD A GREAT
CONFERENCE AND I HOPE WE BLOW
YOUR SOCKS OFF TODAY WITH
AWESOME TECHNICAL CONTENT AND
LOTS OF OPEN SOURCE.  SO NEXT
HAS BEEN AN AMAZING EVENT SO FAR
AND IT'S BEEN GREAT TO MEET
MANY OF YOU IN BREAKOUT SESSIONS
, IN THE HALLWAYS AND EVEN ON
THE STREET.
THE VISION DIANE GREENE SHARED
ON THE NEXT DAY OF NEXT
SHOWCASED THE EVOLUTION OF
GOOGLE CLOUD AND HOW WE'RE
GROWING EXTREMELY QUICKLY WITH E
NTERPRISES AND START-UPS.
YESTERDAY, URS HOLZLE SHOWED US
MANY OF THE NEW RELEASES AND
UPDATES WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON
WITH GOOGLE CLOUD.  THIS WEEK
ALONE, WE'VE ANNOUNCED MORE THAN
30 NEW FEATURES AND PRODUCTS
THAT ARE NOW AVAILABLE FOR E
VERYONE TO TAKE ADVANTAGE, TO
BUILD WHAT'S NEXT.
NOW, TODAY WE WANT TO TAKE TIME
AND TALK ABOUT ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT FUNDAMENTAL
FUNDAMENTALLY DEFINES HOW GOOGLE
APPROACHES THE CLOUD.  TODAY,
WE WANT TO TALK ABOUT OPENNESS.
TO GUIDE US THROUGH THE
COMBINED GENERAL OF OPEN SOURCE
AND GOOGLE IS A PERSON I'VE LONG
ADMIRED.  FIVE-TIME CO-CHAIR OF
OSCON, THE WORLD EPPS GREATEST
OPEN SOURCE CONFERENCE.  SHE NOW
LEADS OPEN SOURCE COMMUNITIES
FOR GOOGLE CLOUD      CLOUD.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN WELCOMING
ANOTHER BAD IaaS WOMAN
BAD ASS WOMAN, SARAH
NOVOTNY.
[ APPLAUSE ]
Sarah Novotny: GOOD MORNING,
FOLKS.  OPENNESS IS ABOUT
SHARING.  OPENNESS IS ABOUT
AGREEING ON COMMON GOALS, AND
OPENNESS IS ABOUT WORKING
TOGETHER TO MAKE BETTER SOFTWARE
AND A BETTER WORLD.
GOOGLE'S COMMITMENT TO OPENNESS
HAS HELPED US HIRE MANY
ENGINEERS AND ALLOWED THEM TO
DEVELOP, CONTRIBUTE TO, AND
SUPPORT MANY OF THE TECHNOLOGIES
THAT ARE RUNNING THE BROADER
INTERNET TODAY.
A 2004 WHITE PAPER ON MAPREDUCE
BECAME THE BASIS FOR MANY
TECHNOLOGIES UNDERLYING THE BIG
DATA ECOSYSTEM.  GOOGLE'S
INTERNAL SYSTEM, BORG, FOR
MANAGING CONTAINERS, WAS
REIMAGINED AS KUBERNETES, AN
OPEN SOURCE CONTAINER
ORCHESTRATION SYSTEM.
THESE ARE SOME OF THE LATEST
EXAMPLES OF COLLABORATION WHERE
OPENNESS HAS INVOLVED OUR
INDUSTRY.
WE AT GOOGLE ARE HUMBLED TO TAKE
-- HUMBLED THAT OVER A BILLION
USERS TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE
SERVICES WE PROVIDE TO OPENLY
SHARE THEIR CONTENT AND SERVICES
, AS WELL AS THEIR DREAMS AND
ACHIEVEMENTS.
IT'S CLICHE TO SAY, BUT WE'RE
STANDING ON THE SHOULDERS OF
GIANTS.  ALL OF THIS IS POSSIBLE
BECAUSE OF THOSE THAT STARTED
THIS JOURNEY TOWARD AN OPEN
WORLD LONG BEFORE GOOGLE WAS AN
IDEA THOUGHT UP BY TWO GRAD
STUDENTS IN SANFORD IN THE LATE
'90s.
THIS MORNING WE'LL HEAR FROM SIX
SPEAKERS SHARING PARTICULAR
FACETS AND BENEFITS OF OPENNESS
AS A PHILOSOPHY.  VINT CERF, JIM
ZEMLIN, ERIC BREWER, CHRIS
WRIGHT, AND JEFF DEAN, AND RAJAT
MONGA.
THIS STORY WILL, I HOPE,
UNDERPIN GOOGLE'S COMMITMENT TO
OPEN CLOUD AND WHY IT IS SO
STRONG.
AS THE INTERNET WAS BEING
CREATED, ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT DECISIONS WAS TO
CREATE AND USE OPEN STANDARDS
AND TECHNOLOGIES TO HELP ENSURE
THAT THE NETWORK WAS BOTH
RESILIENT AND EASY TO
INTERCONNECT AS NEW SYSTEMS CAME
ON LINE.
IT'S THIS COMMITMENT TO OPENNESS
THAT OPENED A WHOLE NEW WORLD
OF INTERCONNECTION AND HAS
ENABLED THE INTERNET TO BECOME A
NEARLY UNIVERSAL MEANS FOR
EXCHANGE OF CODE, INFORMATION,
SERVICES, AND IDEAS.
THE DECISIONS TO MAKE THE
INTERNET BASED ON OPEN STANDARDS
WERE FUNDAMENTAL TO MAKING IT
UNIVERSAL, JUST AS THE GOALS OF
OPEN SOURCE AND AN OPEN CLOUD
ARE CRITICAL TO CREATING THE
NEXT GENERATION OF TECHNICAL
ADVANCES.
VINT CERF CODESIGNED ONE OF THE
KEY PARTS OF THE INTERNET,
TCP/IP.  HE WORKED WITH THE
GROUP THAT HELPED CONNECT THE
FIRST TWO NODES TO ARPANET, RAN
THE INTERNET
INTERNETTING RESEARCH GROUP AND
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM AT DARPA
FROM 1976 TO 1982 AND WAS LATER
RESPONSIBLE FOR HELPING BRING
THE FIRST COMMERCIAL EMAIL
SYSTEM TO THE INTERNET.
HE'S ALSO RESPONSIBLE FOR
HELPING FORM ICANN, WAS THE
FIRST PRESIDENT OF THE INTERNET
SOCIETY, AND CURRENTLY SERVES AS
A COMMISSIONER FOR THE UNITED
NATIONS BROADBAND COMMISSION FOR
DIGITAL DEVELOPMENT.  HE'S ALSO
WORKING ON THE INTERPLANTRY
INTERNET WITH NASA A'S JET PRO
LUGS LABORATORY.  HERE TO SHARE
HIS EXPERIENCE AND KNOWLEDGE
ABOUT HOW OPENNESS WAS A KEY
DESIGN PRINCIPLE FOR TODAY'S
MODERN INTERNET IS VINT CERF.
[ APPLAUSE ]
Vint Cerf: THANK YOU, SARAH.
GOOD MORNING, EVERYONE.  THIS IS
A WONDERFUL OPPORTUNITY TO TALK
ABOUT THE THREAD OF OPENNESS
WHICH WEAVES ITSELF THROUGHOUT
THE INTERNET'S STORY, SO LET'S
START.
CAN I GET THE FIRST -- THERE WE
ARE.
HERE'S AN EXAMPLE OF A
PUBLICATION FROM 1974.  I HAVE
THE FEELING SOME OF YOU MAY NOT
HAVE BEEN BORN THEN.  THIS
CONTAINED THE DESCRIPTION OF THE
INTERNET DESIGN.  IT WAS
PUBLISHED OPENLY BY BOB KHAN AND
ME IN THIS PUBLICATION.  OUR
DESIGN INTENDED TO BE AVAILABLE
ANYWHERE TO EVERYONE WITH NO
BARRIERS, SO WE TOOK NO PATENTS,
WE DIDN'T MAKE ANY INTELLECTUAL
PROPERTY CLAIMS, AND WE DID
THAT ON PURPOSE BECAUSE WE
WANTED THERE TO BE ABSOLUTELY NO
EXECUTION NOT TO ADOPT, TCP/IP
AS AN INTERNATIONAL STANDARD.
SO OPENNESS WAS IMPORTANT TO US
FROM THE GET-GO.
THE REQUEST FOR COMMENTS SERIES,
WHICH I SUSPECT MANY OF YOU ARE
FAMILIAR WITH, WAS STARTED IN
1969 BY MY COLLEAGUE, STEVE
CROCKER, WHO NOW HAPPENS TO BE
CHAIRMAN OF ICANN.  AGAIN,
OPENNESS.  THE INTENT HERE WAS
TO MAKE SURE THAT EVERYONE
INVOLVED IN THE PROJECT AND
OTHER PEOPLE WHO WERE INTERESTED
COULD SEE IN DETAIL HOW THIS
STUFF WORKS, WHAT THE DEBATES
WERE ABOUT VARIOUS CHOICES.
AGAIN, OPEN ACCESS TO EVERYONE.
THE INTERNET ITSELF HAS OPEN
CHARACTERISTICS AND MOST OF YOU,
I'M SURE, ARE VERY FAMILIAR
WITH THAT.  AT THE CORE OF THE
INTERNET IS THE INTERNET
PROTOCOL.  AND IT HAS THIS
INTERESTING PROPERTY.  IT'S
STUPID, RIGHT?  IT DOESN'T KNOW
THE PACKETS IN THE INTERNET
DON'T KNOW HOW THEY'RE BEING
CARRIED, NO IDEA IF IT'S GOING
OTHER SATELLITE LINK OR AN
OPTICAL FIBER AND IT DOESN'T
CARE.  LIKE A POSTCARD DOESN'T
CARE HOW IT'S BEING CARRIED.
AND ON TOP OF EVERYTHING ELSE,
THE INTERNET PACKETS DON'T KNOW
WHAT THEY'RE CARRYING, RIGHT
RIGHT?  THEY HAVE NO IDEA
IT'S A BAG OF BITS GOING FROM
POINT A TO POINT B WITH SOME
PROBABILITY GREATER THAN ZERO.
THAT'S ALL WE ASK IT.  WHAT'S
IMPORTANT IS THAT ANY
INFORMATION THAT HAS HAS BEEN
INTERPRETED AT THE EDGES OF THE
NET.  THIS IS PORAT PART OF THE
END TO END PRINCIPLE.  SO THE
POINT IS WHEN YOU WANT TO ADD A
NEW APPLICATION, YOU DON'T HAVE
TO CHANGE THE NET.  THE NET
DOESN'T KNOW.  THAT'S OPEN WITH
A BIG "O" ."  AND SO ALL THE
OTHER PROTOCOLS THAT YOU SEE
GOING UP TOWARDS THE TOP AND
SPREADING OUT LIKE THIS ARE
EVIDENCE THAT IF YOU AREN'T
HAPPY WITH THE PROTOCOLS THAT
EXIST NOW, GO BUILD YOUR OWN.
IF YOU'RE NOT HAPPY WITH THE
UNDERLYING TRANSPORT MECHANISMS,
FIND ANOTHER ONE    ONE.
SO THIS IS OPEN IN EVERY SENSE
OF THE WORD AND THAT'S WHY SO
MANY NEW APPLICATIONS HAVE BEEN
DEVELOPED OVER THE LAST 30
SOME-ODD YEARS OF OPERATION.
WHY DOES THIS THING -- THERE WE
GO.
SO HERE'S AN EXAMPLE AT GOOGLE.
WE DEVELOPED A NEW PROTOCOL
CALLED QUIC THAT COMBINES THE T
CP PROTOCOL WITH THE TLS
PROTOCOLS AND ADDS A FEW OTHER
FEATURES AS WELL AND THAT JUST
SLIPS RIGHT IN WHERE TCP AND TLS
WOULD NORMALLY GO AND THAT RUNS
RIGHT NOW IN OUR BROWSE
BROWSERS AND IN OUR SERVERS AND
IN OTHER PEOPLE'S SOFTWARE WHO
CHOOSE TO USE THIS PARTICULAR
IDEA.
YOU MIGHT BE SURPRISED TO KNOW
THAT WE WERE PLAYING AROUND WITH
PACKET VOICE AND PACKET VIDEO
IN THE 1970-E.  THIS IS BECAUSE
THE MILITARY KNEW IT WAS GOING
TO HAVE TO USE NETWORKING IN
ORDER TO CARRY VOICE, VIDEO, AND
DATA     DATA.  WE WEREN'T
CARRYING VERY MUCH THOUGH, .  I
CAN TELL YOU OUR BACKBONE SPEEDS
WERE 50 KILOBITS A SECOND BACK
-- THAT WAS "BROADBAND
"BROADBAND."
[ LAUGHTER ]
NOW IT'S A DIAL-UP MODEM.  BUT
WE WERE EXPERIMENTING WITH THE
CONCEPTS AND ACTUALLY TRYING
THIS STUFF OUT.  THE WORLD WIDE
WEB, OF COURSE, CAME ALONG, TIM
PERSONSERLY INCHES THIS IN THE
LATE '80s, EARLY '90s AND IS
FREE TO DO IT, RIGHT?  HE JUST
INVENTS A SET OF PROTOCOLS, HTTP
AND HTML ENCODING AND HE PUTS
THAT UP ON THE NET.  HE DOESN'T
HAVE TO GET PERMISSION.  THE
GUYS THAT STARTED GOOGLE DIDN'T
HAVE TO GET PERMISSION FROM
SOMEBODY TO GO PUT UP THE
SERVICE.  THEY JUST PUT IT UP.
IN THEIR, YOU KNOW,  -- I GUESS
IT WAS IN THEIR DORM ROOM AND
THEN IN A GARAGE.  CLASSIC
SILICON VALLEY STORY      STORY.
BUT THE WHOLE POINT HERE IS
THAT IT'S PERMISSION
PERMISSIONLESS INNOVATION AND
THAT'S WHAT THE INTERNET HAS
BEEN ABOUT AND IS STILL ABOUT
AND THAT'S WHAT'S IMPORTANT TO
YOU.  BECAUSE IF YOU'RE THINKING
ABOUT STARTING NEW BUSINESSES,
YOU WANT TO BE FREE TO INVENT.
YOU DON'T WANT TO HAVE TO GET
PERMISSION TO TRY OUT YOUR IDEAS
.  AND OF COURSE NOW THAT YOU
SEE ALL THE MOBILE APPS AND
CLOUD SERVERS THAT ARE HAPPENING
, AGAIN, EVIDENCE OF THE
PERMISSIONLESSNESS OF THE
INTERNET.
HERE'S ANOTHER EXAMPLE.  IT'S
AMAZING.  EVERYBODY WHO GOT A
BROWSE ER AND WAS CURIOUS HOW
THE HELL DID THEY DO THAT HAD
THE OPPORTUNITY TO GO LOOK AT
THE SOURCE CODE.  BOY, THAT'S
OPEN.  EVERYONE HAD A CHANCE TO
TRY OUT NEW IDEAS, STEAL IDEAS
FROM EVERYBODY ELSE.  THE WHOLE
POINT IS THAT WE GREW THE NOTION
OF WEBMASTER FROM ZERO BY
PEOPLE TRYING EACH OTHER'S CODE
OUT AND, YOU KNOW, MODIFYING IT
AND TRYING OTHER IDEAS AND THOSE
GOT SHARED AND PROPAGATED
ALMOST ORGANICALLY.
THIS IS SUCH A PERFECT EXAMPLE
OF WHY OPEN IS SO IMPORTANT TO
EVERYONE.
THERE'S ANOTHER THING, AND THAT
HAS TO DO WITH THE INSTITUTIONS
THAT ARE PART OF THE INTERNET.
WE DIDN'T CREATE ALL OF THESE AT
THE SAME TIME.  WE CREATED THEM
WHEN THEY WERE NEEDED, SO THE
INTERNET ARCHITECTURE UP OR
DOWN, WHICH USED TO BE CALLED
THE INTERNET CONFIGURATION
CONTROL BOARD WHEN I WAS STILL
IN THE DEFENSE DEPARTMENT, I
NEEDED TO HAVE THE PEOPLE WHO
WERE RUNNING THE PROJECT GET
TOGETHER AND TALK TO EACH OTHER
ABOUT WHAT WAS GOING ON.  I
WANTED THIS TO BE ONLY THE
PEOPLE I PICKED, SO THE NAME OF
THIS THING, INTERNET
CONFIGURATION CONTROL BOARD, WAS
PICKED TO BE AS BORING AS --
SOUNDING AS POSSIBLE, SO NO ONE
WANTED TO BE ON IT EXCEPT THE
PEOPLE I PUT ON IT.  THAT BECAME
THE INTERNET ARCHITECTURE
BOARD, WHICH SPUN OUT THE
INTERNET ENGINEERING TASK FORCE
WHERE ALL OF THE STANDARDS GET
MADE NOW.  THE INTERNET SOCIETY
WAS CREATED IN ORDER TO SUPPORT
THE EMERGING ISSUES TASK FORCE
WHEN THE NATIONAL SCIENCE
FOUNDATION SAID, "WE DON'T WANT
TO SPEND ANY MORE RESEARCH
DOLLARS ON WHAT HAS BECOME A
VERY ACTIVE COMMERCIAL KIND OF
ENVIRONMENT."  SO THE INTERNET
SOCIETY WAS FORMED TO SUPPORT
EITF AND NOW, OF COURSE, IT DOES
A LOT OF OTHER THINGS AS WELL.
ICANN GOT CREATED SIMILARLY
AROUND 1998 WHEN THE GOVERNMENT
DECIDED, U.S. GOVERNMENT
DECIDED, "WHY ARE WE PRETENDING
TO BE IN CHARGE OF INTERNET
ADDRESS ALLOCATION AND DOMAIN
NAME MANAGEMENT AND THE TABLES
FOR THE INTERNET -- FOR THE
INTERNET PROTOCOLS?  WHY ISN'T
THAT IN THE PRIVATE SECTOR?"
AND SO ICANN WAS CREATED AS A
MULTISTAKEHOLDER GROUP
COMPLETELY OPEN, ANYONE IS
ALLOWED TO PARTICIPATE, AND
BECOME PART OF THE POLICYMAKING
APPARATUS.
REGIONAL INTERNET REGISTRIES
WERE CREATED PARTLY FOR
CONVENIENCE, SO TO SPREAD THE
WORKLOAD.  THERE ARE FIVE OF
THEM AROUND THE WORLD AND THEY
HAND OUT INTERNET ADDRESSES TO
ISPs WHO SUBSEQUENTLY MAKE THOSE
AVAILABLE TO USERS.
AND MORE RECENTLY, THE IVING
THIVINGIVING SPUN
IVING         THE
INTERNET GOVERNANCE FORUM
INTERNET
GOVERNANCE FORM WHAT WAS CALLED
THE WSIS, THE WORLD SUMMIT ON
THE INFORMATION SOCIETY.  THIS
WAS ORIGINAL         ORIGINALLY
A MULTILATERAL,
INTERGOVERNMENTAL THING.  VERY
QUICKLY THEY DISCOVERED THERE
WAS MORE TO THE INTERNET THAN
GOVERNMENTS.  IT WAS PEOPLE LIKE
YOU AND ME.  AND SO THAT BLEW
UP INTO THE INTERNET GOVERNANCE
FORUM, A MULTISTAKEHOLDER ANNUAL
EVENT WHICH NOW HAS REGIONAL
EVENTS TO GO WITH IT.
ALL OF THIS STUFF IS WIDE OPEN.
ANYONE IS ALLOWED TO
PARTICIPATE AND YOU SHOULD TOO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
[ APPLAUSE ]
Sarah Novotny: THANKS, VINT.
NOW THAT WE'VE ESTABLISHED A
LONG STANDING HISTORY OF
OPENNESS AS AN UNDERPINNING
PHILOSOPHY BEHIND OUR MODERN
COMMUNICATIONS MARVEL, THE
INTERNET, IT'S IMPORTANT TO
UNDERSTAND THAT ADOPTION IS HOW
WE'VE COME TO THIS PLACE IN
HISTORY, TO HELP US UNDERSTAND
HOW OPEN SOURCE HAS LEARNED TO
BALANCE THE TENSIONS BETWEEN
OPENNESS AND BUSINESS NEEDS.
I'D LIKE TO INTRODUCE JIM
ZEMLIN, THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE LINUX FOUNDATION.  PLEASE
JOIN ME IN WELCOMING JIM.
[ APPLAUSE ]
Jim Zemlin: THANK YOU.  THANK
YOU.
WOW.  FOLLOWING ONE OF THE
FATHERS OF THE INTERNET, BIG
PRESSURE.
I'M OLD ENOUGH TO HAVE BEEN
AROUND IN 1974, BUT YOUNG ENOUGH
TO HAVE STILL RUN A DIAL-UP
BBS.  SO I'M FLATTERED TO BE
HERE.  AND I'M HONORED TO WORK
AT AN ORGANIZATION THAT'S HOME
TO ONE OF THE MOST SUCCESSFUL
OPEN SOURCE PROJECTS IN THE
WORLD.  AND I DON'T NEED TO
CONVINCE THIS CROWD HOW
IMPORTANT OPEN SOURCE IS.  BUT I
WANT TO REMIND YOU OF HOW
POWERFUL OPEN SOURCE IS.  JUST
LOOK AT THESE STATISTICS, AT HOW
FAR COLLABORATIVE INVESTMENT
HAS COMES.  TENS OF MILLIONS OF
FILES, MILLIONS OF LINES OF
CODES, THOUSANDS OF DEVELOPERS
AND JUST ONE OPEN SOURCE
PROJECT.  AND THESE STATS ARE
COMPELLING, BUT THIS IS MY
FAVORITE STATISTIC ABOUT LINUX.
10,000 LINES OF CODE ADDED.
5,000 LINES OF CODE REMOVED,
ABOUT 1800 MODIFY IED EVERY
SINGLE DAY.  365 DAYS A YEAR.
THERE IS NO ORGANIZATION ON
EARTH THAT CAN INDEPENDENTLY
KEEP UP WITH THE PACE OF
DEVELOPMENT THAT'S REPRESENTED
BY MODERN OPEN SOURCE PROCESSES.
IN FACT, OPEN SOURCE HAS
BECOME THE NEW NORM FOR SOFTWARE
DEVELOPMENT.  I MEAN, REALLY
NOBODY BUILDS ANYTHING THESE
DAYS WITHOUT USING OPEN SOURCE
CODE.  YOU KNOW, THE INTERNET IS
REALLY BUILT ON OPEN SOURCE,
WHETHER IT'S GOOGLE, FACEBOOK,
AMAZON, YOU NAME IT.  IT'S ALL
BUILT ON LINUX AND A VARIETY OF
OPEN SOURCE.
IN FACT, IT'S MORE THAN A NORM
FOR SOFTWARE IN THE INTERNET,
OPEN HAS BECOME A NEW ECONOMIC
NORM, AN INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
NORM AS WE CREATE MORE AND MORE
COMPLEX SYSTEMS.  THAT NORM SAYS
SOMETHING VERY, VERY SIMPLE BUT
HAS BEEN WRITTEN ABOUT IN
HUNDREDS AND HUNDREDS OF BOOKS.
AND THE SIMPLE CONCEPT IS, ALL
OF US ARE SMARTER THAN ANY ONE
OF US.
AND I WOULD GO SO FAR AS TO
ARGUE THAT ORGANIZATIONS,
DEVELOPERS, ANYONE WHO DOES NOT
HARVEST THIS GREAT SHARED VALUE,
THAT DOESN'T PARTICIPATE IN
THIS COLLECTIVE INNOVATION WILL
FAIL.
AND I HAVE SOME GOOD NEWS FOR
YOU.
THE GOOD NEWS IS THERE'S A LOT
OF OPEN SOURCE OUT THERE.
I MEAN, LOOK AT THIS.  JUST ON
GITHUB ALONE THERE ARE 50
MILLION OPEN SOURCE
REPOSITORIES.  AND WITH THIS
WEALTH OF CODE AND IDEAS AND
COLLABORATION, ONE OF THE
QUESTIONS THAT I GET ALL OF THE
TIME IS WHICH PROJECTS REALLY
MATTER?  I MEAN, THEY'RE ALL
GREAT BUT WHICH PROJECTS CAN I
BET MY COMPANY ON? , IF I'M
BUILDING A CLOUD?  WHAT CAN I
BET MY SAFETY ON IF I'M USING
OPEN SOURCE FOR AN AUTOMOBILE
SYSTEM?  WHICH ALMOST EVERY
MODERN PRODUCTION VEHICLE USES
TODAY.
AND WE SPEND A LOT OF TIME AT
THE LINUX FOUNDATION LOOKING AT
THAT QUESTION.  AND OUR IDEA IS
THAT THE ANSWER TO THAT QUESTION
ARE THAT THE OPEN SOURCE
PROJECTS THAT MATTER THE MOST
ARE THOSE THAT HAVE SUSTAINABLE
ECOSYSTEMS, WHERE RICH COMMUNITY
SOLVES A BIG PROBLEM, CREATES
VALUE.  THAT VALUE IS CONSUMED
BY COMPANIES,
LIKE GOOGLE, MICROSOFT, AMAZON,
FACEBOOK.  WHO THEN CREATE
PROFIT.  GOVERNMENTS MAY SAVE
MONEY, INCREASE TRANSPARENCY.
AND THEN THAT VALUE, IN PART, IS
HARVESTED BACK INTO THE PROJECT
WHICH BEGETS BETTER CODE,
LATHER, RINSE,
REPEAT.  THAT'S WHAT APACHE
BEAM AND LINUX FOUNDATION REALLY
DO.  VICINITY TALKING ABOUT
CREATING INSTITUTIONS WHEN THEY
TALKED ABOUT WITH THE GROWTH OF
THE INTERNET.  WE'RE CREATING
THE SAME KIND OF INSTITUTIONS TO
ENABLE THE GROWTH OF OPEN
SOURCE.  AND THESE INSTITUTIONS
ALLOW COMPETITORS AND
COLLABORATORS TO TRUST EACH
OTHER BY CREATING THE
INSTITUTIONS THAT ENABLE THAT
TRUST.  A GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE
TO MAKE DECISIONS, A DEVELOPMENT
PROCESS THAT ENABLES PEOPLE TO
SCALE OUT DEVELOPMENT AND
SUSTAIN THAT DEVELOPMENT FOR A
LONG TIME.  INFRASTRUCTURE,
WHETHER IT'S THINGS LIKE GITHUB
OR THE WIDE VARIETY OF VERSION
CONTROL SYSTEMS, SOMEBODY NEEDS
TO LAND A PATCH SOMEWHERE,
THAT'S WHAT THESE ORGANIZATIONS
PROVIDE.
ECOSYSTEM DEVELOPMENT, HOW DO
YOU GET MORE DEVELOPERS TO THE
PARTY?  AND THEN I.P.
MANAGEMENT, WHAT LICENSE IS THE
CODE UNDER?  WHO OWNS THE
TRADEMARK?  HOW DO YOU GOVERN
THE INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY
SHARING?  HOW DO YOU SHARE WHAT
YOU WANT TO SHARE AND KEEP WHAT
YOU WANT TO KEEP?  THAT'S WHAT
ORGANIZATIONS LIKE MINE AND
OTHER INSTITUTIONS ARE DOING.
AND OPEN SOURCE PROJECTS THAT
LEAN ON THESE TEND TO BE THE
MOST ENDURING.  THAT'S WHY LAST
YEAR GOOGLE APPROACHED US AND
SAID:  WE WOULD LIKE TO GIVE UP
KUBERNETES.  WE'RE GOING TO GIVE
YOU THE INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY
ASSETS, THE TRADEMARK AND SO
FORTH.  WE'RE GOING TO CREATE A
SHARED DEVELOPMENT MODEL WITH
OUR COMPETITORS.  AND SINCE THAT
HAPPENED, KUBERNETES HAS BEEN A
ROCKET SHIP.  IT IS ON A
TRAJECTORY SIMILAR TO LINUX IN
TERMS OF BECOMING ESSENTIALLY
THE LINUX OF THE CLOUD IN TERMS
OF THE DEVELOPER MOMENTUM, THE
NUMBER OF PULL REQUESTS TIMES
DEVELOPERS.  IT'S AN INSANELY
FAST
GROWING PROJECT.  WHICH LEADS
ME TO THE LAST POINT, WHICH IS I
WORK WITH OVER A THOUSAND
ORGANIZATIONS, LARGELY
COMPANIES, ALL OVER THE
WORLD.  AND COMPANIES DON'T
COME TO
ME AND ASK ABOUT CODE.  WHAT'S
TENSORFLOW?  I WANT TO SEE THE
CODE.  THEY ASK ME ABOUT HOW TO
SHARE.  THE BIGGEST PROBLEM IN
SHARING -- AND THIS
IS THE ONE THING YOU SHOULD
REMEMBER FROM ME TODAY -- IS
BEING A LEADER IN OPEN SOURCE
TAKES WORK.  THE HUMAN ASPECT
TAKES WORK, BEING ABLE TO PULL
CODE IN, MODIFY THAT CODE, SHARE
THAT CODE BACK TAKES A PROCESS.
AND GOOGLE IS ONE OF THE MASTERS
OF THAT PROCESS.  AND I WANT TO
TIP MY HAT TO GOOGLE.
YOU KNOW, YOU TALK -- YOU HEAR
ABOUT THE TERM "GIFFY" WHEN
KUBERNETES WAS OPEN SOURCE,
EVERYBODY COULD TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF THIS CONTAINER TECHNOLOGY AND
ALL THIS GREAT
CODE.  WHAT ANOTHER INSIGHT I
CAN GIVE YOU WORKING WITH CAT
OLMAN AND OTHERS IN THE OPEN
SOURCE PROJECT OFFICES, CODE
FLOWS IN AND OUT OF GOOGLE
SEAMLESSLY.  IT'S INTENTIONAL.
LEARN IT.  AND IF YOU LEARN
THIS, YOU'LL BE ABLE TO HARVEST
THAT SHARED R&D AND SUCCEED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
[ APPLAUSE ]
Sarah Novotny: THANK YOU, JIM.
IT'S WONDERFUL TO HEAR THAT
GOOGLE IS PERCEIVED AS A
POSITIVE INFLUENCE IN THE OPEN
WORLD.  AND I CAN'T BE HAPPIER
TO HEAR KUBERNETES REFERRED TO
AS THE LINUX OF THE CLOUD.
BUT MOVING ON, SAM RAMJI, WHO WE
WILL HEAR FROM AGAIN LATER,
FREQUENTLY REFERS TO OPEN SOURCE
AND COLLABORATIVE WORK AS A
POSITIVE SUM GAME.  GOOGLE HAS
SEEN THIS AS A FORCE MULTIPLIER
AND HAS BEEN INTENTIONAL IN LONG
STANDING IN OUR SUPPORT OF OPEN
SOURCE PROJECTS.  ERIC BREWER,
THE VP OF INFRASTRUCTURE AND A
PROFESSOR AT UC BERKELEY FOCUSES
ON ALL ASPECTS OF
INTERNET-BASED SYSTEMS,
INCLUDING CLOUD COMPUTING,
SCALABILITY, CONTAINERS AND
STORAGE.  AS
A RESEARCHER, HE HAS LED
PROJECTS ON SCALABLE SERVERS,
NETWORK INFRASTRUCTURE, IoT AND
THE CAP
THEOREM.  TODAY I'M DELIGHTED
TO HEAR HIS THOUGHTS ON WHY AN
OPEN CLOUD AND OPEN SOURCE
INVESTMENT IS AS IMPORTANT AS AN
OPEN INTERNET WAS 40 YEARS AGO.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN WELCOMING
ERIC BREWER.
[ APPLAUSE ]
Eric Brewer: THANK YOU, SARAH.
ALL RIGHT.  FANTASTIC TO BE
HERE.
IMAGINE THAT YOU ARE IN A NEW
MARKET AND IT'S THE NEXT BIG
THING, GIANT, GIANT, GIANT.  BUT
YOU HAVE SOME REALLY BIG
COMPETITORS AND THEY HAVE A
MULTIYEAR HEAD START ON YOU.
HOW ARE YOU GOING TO COMPETE?
WELL, THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED TO
LINUX.  THESE ARE PROJECTS THAT
GOOGLE'S CONTRIBUTED TO FOR MORE
THAN TEN YEARS, A DECADE'S
WORTH OF CONTRIBUTION IN THESE
PROJECTS ALONE.  AND IN THE CASE
OF LINUX, 20 YEARS AGO THE NEXT
NEW THING WAS THE WEB AND
INTERNET SERVICES.  AND HONESTLY
LINUX WAS NOT A VERY GOOD
INTERNET SERVICES OPERATING
SYSTEM.  YAHOO! USED BSD.  AND
THEY HAD A MULTIYEAR HEAD START
ON LINUX IN THIS SPACE.  BUT
LINUX WON.  WHY DID LINUX WIN?
LINUX WON BECAUSE IT WAS OPEN
BUT REALLY BECAUSE IT HAD A
HIGHER RATE OF INNOVATION.  AND
SO WHAT MATTERS IS NOT WHERE YOU
START, WHAT MATTERS IS YOUR
RATE OF INNOVATION.
EVEN IN CONTAINERS WHERE WE HAD
TEN YEARS OF CONTRIBUTIONS TO
LINUX FROM GOOGLE, THAT STARTED
OUT AS SOMETHING SIMPLE TO DO
KIND OF RESOURCE MANAGEMENT,
THINGS LIKE CPU SETS AND THEN C
GROUPS, ADDITIONS TO THE LINUX
KERNEL THAT ALLOWED YOU TO KIND
OF MANAGE YOUR RESOURCES.  AND,
OF COURSE, EVENTUAL LED TO
DOCKER AND KUBERNETES WHICH IS
WHERE WE ARE TODAY.
NOW, THERE'S A WHOLE OTHER PIECE
HERE WHICH IS OPEN SOURCE IS
THE KIND OF LEADERSHIP OF AN
ECOSYSTEM.  SO YOU PROBABLY
HEARD OF ANDROID AND CHROME,
THOSE ARE OPEN SOURCE PROJECTS
CREATED NOT FOR THEIR SOURCE
CODE BUT FOR THEIR ECOSYSTEMS.
THE ECOSYSTEM IS HOW YOU STEER A
LARGE COMMUNITY IN A
COLLABORATIVE WAY.
AND CERTAINLY IN THE CLOUD
SPACE, TENSORFLOW WHICH YOU WILL
HEAR ABOUT FROM JEFF DEAN IN A
LITTLE BIT, AND KUBERNETES, ARE
IN THIS MOLD.  WE ARE ABLING TO
CREATE OPEN ECOSYSTEMS THAT HAVE
HIGH RATES OF INNOVATION.  AND
IF YOU'VE DONE -- KNOW ANYTHING
ABOUT KUBERNETES, YOU KNOW IT
HAS A SUPER CRAZY HIGH RATE OF
INNOVATION.  THAT'S KIND OF THE
WHOLE POINT.
OTHER THINGS ON THIS LIST LIKE
BAZEL AND gRPC REPS A DIFFERENT
SO I WHICH ARE OPEN SOURCE
PROJECTS WE CREATED BECAUSE WE
FEEL LIKE THERE'S A GOOGLE WAY
OF DOING SOMETHING INTERNALLY
THAT WASN'T UNDERSTOOD
EXTERNALLY.  gRPC IS BASED ON
SOMETHING CALLED STUBBY.  AND
BAZEL IS BASED ON AN INTERNAL
BUILD SYSTEM CALLED BLAZE, BOTH
OF WHICH WE REALLY LIKE AND WE
WOULD LIKE MORE PEOPLE TO USE;
RIGHT?  AND IN PARTICULAR, WE
WOULD LIKE MORE PEOPLE TO
CONTRIBUTE TO AND TO UNDERSTAND
AND EVOLVE.
NOW, THAT'S ANOTHER KIND OF OPEN
SOURCENESS, THE LEADERSHIP
PART.  TAKE A LITTLE ASIDE FOR A
MINUTE.  YOU KNOW THOSE SLIDES
YOU MAKE SOMETIMES WHERE YOU PUT
A WHOLE BUNCH OF LITTLE TEXT ON
IT THAT NOBODY CAN READ AND YOU
DO THAT BECAUSE YOU WANT TO
SHOW HOW MANY THINGS THERE ARE,
WELL, LOOK AT ALL THESE SCREENS!
THIS IS A THOUSAND-PLUS OPEN
SOURCE PROJECTS TO WHICH
GOOGLERS CONTRIBUTED IN 2016.
SO I HAD TO PUT IN THESE EXTRA
SCREENS TO FIT THEM ALL, EXCEPT
THAT THIS IS ONLY 10% OF THE
15,000 THAT GOOGLERS CONTRIBUTED
TO IN 2016.  2500 OF THOSE HAD
EXTENSIVE CONTRIBUTIONS; RIGHT?
I WOULD SAY LEGITIMATE, ONGOING
THINGS THAT WERE EVOLVING.  AND
IN TOTAL, AGAIN, JUST IN 2016,
287,000 COMMITS FROM GOOGLERS
USING THEIR GOOGLE.COM EMAIL
ADDRESSES, MEANING THAT'S
WORK-RELATED, NOT COUNTING THE
MANY, MANY THOUSANDS MORE THAT
WE DON'T KNOW OF WHICH ARE ON
THEIR PERSONAL AND GMAIL
ACCOUNTS; RIGHT?  THIS IS STUFF
WHERE WE BELIEVE IT'S WORTH THE
INVESTMENT TO MAKE THESE SYSTEMS
BETTER.
FUNDAMENTALLY DIFFERENT VIEW ON
WHAT WE WANT TO GET OUT OF THIS.
THERE'S ANOTHER KIND OF OPEN
SOURCE SUPPORT WHICH IS ACTUALLY
JUST PLAIN OLD FINANCIAL.  SO
THESE ARE FOUNDATIONS THAT WE
SUPPORT DIRECTLY, EVENTS.  WE
RUN 50 -- OR HELP RUN, FUND 50
TO 75 DIFFERENT KINDS OF EVENTS
THROUGHOUT THE YEAR, ALL OVER
THE WORLD.  THIS IS ALSO WHERE
THINGS LIKE GOOGLE SUMMER OF
CODE FIT, TRYING TO EXPAND THE
COMMUNITY OF OPEN SOURCE
CONTRIBUTORS.  THERE'S ANOTHER
KIND OF SUPPORT AS WELL WHICH IS
SECURITY.  WE LIVE IN A
DIFFICULT TIME FROM A SECURITY
VIEWPOINT AND WE HAVE A SHARED
FATE.  WE ARE ALL USING THE SAME
CORE PIECES, AND WE WILL MAKE
IT OR NOT, TOGETHER.  SO AN
IMPORTANT KIND OF CONTRIBUTION
IS TO IMPROVE THE SECURITY OF
THE WORLD'S SYSTEMS AND OPEN
SOURCE MAKES THAT SIGNIFICANTLY
EASIER.  SO IN THE LAST YEAR,
FEW YEARS, GOOGLE HAS FIXED MORE
THAN 100 SECURITY BUGS IN LINUX
AND CHROME.  AND IN DECEMBER WE
RELEASED A TOOL CALLED OPEN
FUZZ.  AND THE PURPOSE OF OPEN
FUZZ IS ESSENTIALLY TO ALLOW YOU
TO DO FUZZ TESTING ON YOUR OWN
CODE AND IMPROVE YOUR SECURITY.
AND, IN FACT, IT WILL EVEN HELP
YOU MAKE THE RIGHT PATCH.
SO ALL THIS IS TO SAY THAT OPEN
MATTERS TO GOOGLE.  BUT I'D GO
FARTHER AND SAY OPEN MATTERS
MORE FOR THE CLOUD BECAUSE IN
THE CLOUD, WE ARE ON A JOINT
MISSION TO BUILD THE WORLD'S
SOFTWARE; RIGHT?  IT IS
FUNDAMENTALLY COLLABORATIVE.
THE COLLABORATION IS ON THE
CODE.  AND SO OUR STRATEGY HERE
IS BE THE OPEN CLOUD, HAVE THE
FASTER RATE OF INNOVATION, HAVE
MORE COLLABORATION.  BE THE
PLACE WHERE COLLABORATION
OCCURS.
AND IT'S NOT COMPLETELY
ALTRUISTIC; RIGHT?  WHEN I GOT
TO GOOGLE SIX YEARS AGO, ONE OF
ITS CHALLENGES WHICH REMAINS A
LITTLE BIT, BUT NOT AS MUCH, IS
THAT ITS INTERNAL SYSTEMS,
ALTHOUGH THEY TRUE FROM MANY
OPEN SOURCE PROJECTS, WERE VERY
EXOTIC.  THEY HAVE THEIR OWN
LITTLE INTERNAL SYSTEMS OF WAYS
TO BUILD THINGS.  WHEN YOU COME
IN AS AN OUTSIDE DEVELOPER, IT
WAS VERY DIFFICULT TO BE
PRODUCTIVE IN THE FIRST SIX
MONTHS BECAUSE WHATEVER YOU KNEW
COMING IN, YOU HAD TO LEARN
DIFFERENT SYSTEMS TO MAKE
PROGRESS.
AS WE MOVE TO OPEN SYSTEMS,
THINGS LIKE KUBERNETES
AND TENSORFLOW, GOOGLE BENEFITS
BY BEING MORE LIKE THE REST OF
THE WORLD.  THAT'S A MUCH MORE
SUSTAINABLE PLACE TO BE.  SO
THAT'S ANOTHER REASON WE'RE
EMBRACING OPEN SOURCE IN A
FUNDAMENTAL WAY.LET ME CLOSE ON
ONE LAST THOUGHT,
WHICH IS IN THE END, THE REASON
IT MATTERS TO CUSTOMERS IS I
THINK THE FREEDOM.  AND BY
FREEDOM, IN THIS
Sarah Novotny: OPEN MATTERS
MORPHOTHE CLOUD.  THAT'S A
PRETTY POWERFUL MESSAGE.
CO-DEVELOPMENT WITH OUR
CUSTOMERS AND OUR PARTNERS AS A
PHILOSOPHICAL UNDERPINNING OF
THE GOOGLE CLOUD STRATEGY.
HYBRID AND MULTI-CLOUD IS NOT A
WAY POINT ON YOUR JOURNEY BUT A
GOAL THAT EMPOWERS YOU AND
ALLOWS -- WHILE ALLOWING AND
ENCOURAGING YOU, OUR CUSTOMERS,
TO CHOOSE THE SERVICES WHICH
MEET YOUR NEEDS.
WE WANT TO SUPPORT YOU AND THE
TOOLS YOU KNOW AND HAVE, WHILE
ALLOWING YOU TO TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF THE TOOLING AND
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT ONLY GOOGLE
CAN PROVIDE.
THIS SORT OF COLLABORATION WITH
CUSTOMERS AND PARTNERS THROUGH
OPEN SOURCE IS SOMETHING THAT
RED HAT HAS A LONG HISTORY OF
DOING WELL.  CHRIS WRIGHT, VICE
PRESIDENT AND CHIEF TECHNOLOGIST
AT RED HAT, HAS ALSO WORKED FOR
MANY OF HIS 20 YEARS DIRECTLY
ON UPSTREAM OPEN SOURCE
TECHNOLOGIES LIKE LINUX, XEN, K
VM, OPEN SWITCH AND OPEN STACK.
TODAY, HE'S GOING TO SHARE WITH
US HOW COLLABORATION, OPEN
SOURCE, AND ENTERPRISES CAN WORK
TOGETHER TO BENEFIT THE
INDUSTRY.
IT'S MY PLEASURE TO INTRODUCE
CHRIS WRIGHT.
[ APPLAUSE ]
Chris Wright: ALL RIGHT.  REALLY
GREAT TO BE HERE.  IT'S UNUSUAL
FOR ME TO BE ON A STAGE AFTER
HEARING ABOUT THE OPENNESS AND
INTRODUCTION OF THE INTERNET
INTERNET, SO I'M EXCITED
TO BE HERE TO SHARE WITH YOU
SOME OF MY THOUGHTS AND MY
EXPERIENCES IN OPEN SOURCE
COLLABORATION AND BRINGING THAT
TO
THE ENTERPRISE.
SO FIRST, I'LL START WITH A
PERSONAL STORY.
ABOUT 12 YEARS AGO, BRIAN
STEVENS, WHO WAS THEN AT RED HAT
, CONTACTED ME ABOUT JOINING RED
HAT, AND I WAS 100% FOCUSED ON
UPSTREAM DEVELOPMENT.  I WAS
DEFINITELY SKEPTICAL ABOUT WHAT
THE RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN
COMMERCIALIZATION AND ENTERPRISE
FOCUS MIGHT DO TO MY FOCUS IN
TERMS OF UPSTREAM, AND SO I CAME
UP WITH A LIST OF REASONS, ALL
THE REASONS WHY I WAS GOING TO
SAY "NO" ."  AND BRIAN
NEUTRALIZED EACH ONE OF THOSE.
I HAD ONE FINAL REASON AND THAT
WAS MY WIFE AND I WERE EXPECTING
OUR FIRST CHILD AND I THOUGHT
MAYBE TWO -- TWO BIG CHANGES AT
ONCE ISN'T A GREAT IDEA.
BUT ONE THING REALLY PERSISTED
AND STUCK WITH ME, AND THAT WAS
THE IDEA THAT I REALLY LIKE
WORKING WITH CUSTOMERS,
UNDERSTANDING CUSTOMER PROBLEMS,
AND HELPING THEM SOLVE THEIR
ISSUES IN THE CONTEXT OF OPEN
SOURCE.
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT WE DO AT RED
HAT.  WE SPEND OUR TIME WITH
OUR CUSTOMERS DISTILLING THEIR
REQUIREMENTS INTO UPSTREAM CODE,
DELIVERING THAT AS PRODUCTS.
REALLY HARNESSING OPEN SOURCE I
NNOVATION TO DELIVER THE VALUE
OF OPEN SOURCE TO THE ENTERPRISE
.
SO LET'S TAKE A LOOK, WHAT IS T
HE ENTERPRISE?  YOU LOOK INSIDE
THE ENTERPRISE AND IT IS A
COLLECTION OF HIGHLY
HETEROGENOUS SYSTEMS THAT HAVE
EVOLVED OVER LONG PERIODS OF
TIME.  INSIDE THE ENTERPRISE IS
A BIT OF EVERYTHING.  YOU LOOK
AT COMPUTE.  YOU'VE GOT
MAINFRAME, YOU'VE GOT RISK
LINUX, YOU'VE GOT MODERN X86 AND
LINUX.  ON THE NETWORKING SIDE,
YOU'VE GOT SWITCHES AND ROUTERS
AND SERVER NICK E FROM
DIFFERENT VENDORS, DIFFERENT
GENERATIONS OF TECHNOLOGY,
STORAGE, FIBER CHANNEL, ETHERNET
, DIRECT ATTACHED.  YOU'VE GOT
DIFFERENT AUTHENTICATION FROM L
DAP TO ACTIVE DIRECTORY.  YOU'VE
GOT PROCESS CHANGE MANAGEMENT,
ISO AND ITO.  ALL OF THIS
CREATES A COMPLEX SYSTEM.  AND
COMPLEX SYSTEMS -- WITH COMPLEX
ITY COMES FRAGILE ITY.  THE
MISSION-CRITICAL NATURE OF OPEN
-- OF ENTERPRISE APPLICATIONS
CREATES A RISK "AVERSE
ENVIRONMENT AND THESE SOLID
AREAS OF EXPERTISE SLOWS
COLLABORATION.
SO THE ENTERPRISE DATA CENTER IS
AN ARTISAN, HAND-
HAND-CRAFTED, SPECIAL SNOWFLAKE.
THE I.T. GROUPS HAVE BEEN SORT
OF RELEGATED TO A COST CENTER,
WITH A MANDATE FROM CIOS TO
REALLY REDUCE COSTS OR DO
MORPHOLESS.
AND HERE OPEN SOURCE COMES IN
AND SOMETHING LIKE LINUX BUILDS
A STANDARD PLATFORM,
DECOUPLE ING THE HARDWARE LAYER
FROM THE APPLICATION LAYER.  THE
INDUSTRY-WIDE COLLABORATION
HELPS CRAFT THIS CORE PLATFORM
AND ADAPT IT TO ALL OF THE
UNIQUE REQUIREMENTS THAT YOU
FIND IN ANY ONE ENTERPRISE.
AGAIN, THAT'S WHAT WE'RE DOING
WITH OUR CUSTOMERS.  WE'RE --
WE'RE UNDERSTANDING THOSE
REQUIREMENTS.  WE'RE TAKING
THOSE INTO THE UPSTREAM
COMMUNITIES, DEVELOPING CODE,
AND DELIVERING THOSE AS PRODUCTS
AND SUPPORTING THAT WITH OUR
CUSTOMER.
BUT THE ENTERPRISE IS CHANGING.
THE BUSINESS WORLD IS MUCH MORE
COMPETITIVE TODAY.  THINGS ARE
MOVING QUICKLY.  AND IT'S
SOFTWARE THAT DIFFERENTIATES
BUSINESSES.
THE ABILITY TO ADAPT TO MARKET
CHANGES REQUIRES EFFICIENCY.
YOU NEED TO BE ABLE TO BUILD
HIGH-VALUE SOFTWARE AND DELIVER
IT QUICKLY. .
IN ORDER TO DO THAT, YOU NEED TO
STANDARDIZE AND AUTOMATE FOR
BOTH DEVELOPERS AND OPERATIONS
EFFICIENCY.
THE ENTERPRISE IS REALLY LOOKING
TO THE WEBSCALE COMPANIES TO
UNDERSTAND HOW THEY CAN IMPROVE
THIS EFFICIENCY.  BUILDING
THINGS OUT OF MICRO-SERVICE
SOFTWARE ARCHITECTURES, USING
CONTAINERS TO PACKAGE UP
SERVICES AND DIRECT DEPENDENCY
IES, USING CICD PIPELINE TO
DELIVER THIS INTO A HYBRID CLOUD
AT CLOUD SCALE.
RISK IS MITIGATED BY SMALL IN
INCREMENTAL CHANGE AND THOSE
SILOS ARE BROKEN DOWN BY
CROSS-FUNCTIONAL TEAMS.  SO WE B
UILT OPEN SHIFT TO ADDRESS THOSE
NEEDS FOR OUR CUSTOMERS, AND
OPEN SHIFT -- YOU KNOW, BUILDING
THIS KIND OF MODERN WEBSCALE
APPLICATION PLATFORM, WE BUILT
IT OUT OF LOW-LEVEL LINUX
CONTAINER BUILDING BLOCKS.
SO INSIDE OPEN SHIFT, WE HAD A
UNIQUE TO OPEN SHIFT
IMPLEMENTATION OF CONTAINERS AND
CONTAINER ORCHESTRATION.  YOU
COULD CALL IT OUR OWN SNOWFLAKE.
OPEN SOURCE COMMUNITIES ARE
REALLY DRIVING TECHNOLOGY
INNOVATION.  SO YOU SEE
CONTAINERS GO MAINSTREAM THROUGH
TOOLS LIKE DOCKER.  THE
EXPERIENCE FROM BORG CAPTURED
AND BROUGHT TO MAINSTREAM BY
KUBERNETES.  AND WHAT WE SAW WAS
AN OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE THAT
INNOVATION, RE-BASE OURSELVES AS
OPEN SHIFT ONTO THESE MAIN
STREAM PROJECTS AND DELIVER THAT
VALUE TO OUR CUSTOMERS WHILE
BEING ABLE TO TAKE ON THE RAPID
INNOVATION IN THESE COMMUNITIES
THAT ARE MUCH LARGER THAN
OURSELVES.
SO LETTING GO A LITTLE BIT
REALLY GAVE US A HUGE -- YOU
KNOW, A HUGE LIFT.
TODAY, WE'RE NOT JUST
CONTRIBUTING TO OPEN SHIFT OR
DOCKER OR KUBERNETES, BUT WE'RE
CONTRIBUTING TO THE COMMUNITY
AT-LARGE AND WE'RE CONTRIBUTING
TO OUR PARTNERS AND COMPETITORS.
WE'RE HELPING GKE.  WE'RE
HELPING OTHER KUBERNETES-BASED
DISTRIBUTIONS.
OUR DEVELOPERS ARE THRILLED BY
THE SUCCESS STORY AND THE
CONTRIBUTION THAT THEY'VE HAD TO
SOMETHING LIKE POKEMON GO.
WHAT A COOL STORY, AND TO KNOW
THAT YOU'VE BEEN A PART OF THAT
IS A GREAT SENSE OF -- BRINGS A
GREAT SENSE OF SATISFACTION.
SO OPEN SOURCE COLLABORATION
BENEFITS EVERYONE.
DIVERSITY IS A REALLY IMPORTANT
COMPONENT OF THE COMMUNITIES
THAT WE'RE BUILDING HERE, AND IF
YOU LOOK TO ECOLOGY, THERE ARE
A LOT OF STUDIES SHOWING
BIODIVERSITY CREATES A STRONG
ECOSYSTEM.
HERE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
DIVERSITY OF USERS, DIVERSITY OF
DEVELOPERS, DIVERSITY OF
CUSTOMERS AND VENDORS, DIVERSITY
OF USE CASES AND REQUIREMENTS
DRIVEN BY THESE CUSTOMERS AND
VENDORS ADDRESSING DIFFERENT
MARKETS.  AND THE END RESULT, IN
AN OPEN SOURCE COLLABORATIVE
COMMUNITY, IS CONTINUAL R
EFINEMENT, CODE REFACTORING
REFACTORING,
ARCHITECTURE AL IMPROVEMENTS TO
TAKE ON ALL THOSE REQUIREMENTS.
BUILDING A PLATFORM THAT IS
MORE MAINTAINABLE AND
SUSTAINABLE INTO THE FUTURE WILL
CONTINUE OVER TIME TO GROW AND
CHANGE AND ADAPT, AND THAT IS
EXACTLY WHAT WE'RE DOING
TOGETHER TODAY IN COMMUNITIES
LIKE KUBERNETES AND WE LOOK TO
CONTINUE DOING THAT TOGETHER
TOGETHER.  THANK YOU.
[ APPLAUSE ]
Sarah Novotny: COLLABORATION AND
DIVERSITY OF THOUGHT ONLY MAKE
OUR PROJECTS STRONGER.  OPEN
SOURCE DEVELOPMENT IN ACTIVE
COMMUNITIES ENABLE PERSPECTIVES
THAT ANY ONE COMPANY DEVELOPING
A PRODUCT CANNOT SEE.  WORKING
TOGETHER MAKES OPEN SOURCE
PLATFORM AND INFRASTRUCTURE
SOFTWARE AND PROJECTS STRONGER
AND MORE USEFUL TO A BROADER
ARRAY OF USERS.
IN ADDITION TO ALL THE PROJECTS
WHICH GOOGLE HAS CONTRIBUTED TO
OVER ITS LIFETIME, THERE ARE
HUNDREDS OF PROJECTS THAT GOOGLE
HAS FOUNDED AND MAINTAINS IN A
TRANSPARENT MANNER.  CHRIS
MENTIONED ONE OF OUR HIGHLIGHTS.
KUBERNETES BEGAN AS A COMPANY-
LED PROJECT AND IS GROWING
TOWARD COMMUNITY LEADERSHIP.  A
FEW STATISTICS ON THE KUBERNETES
PROJECT.  AGAIN, MY FAVORITE
FAVORITE.  SHOWED THE
CRAZY LEVEL OF ENGAGEMENT WE
HAVE.  WHILE WE HAVE MORE THAN A
THOUSAND CODE CONTRIBUTORS OVER
THE LIFETIME OF THE PROJECT,
THERE ARE MANY MORE WAYS TO
PARTICIPATE IN OPEN SOURCE.
IN FEBRUARY, MORE
THAN 700 PEOPLE COMMENTED ON
AND CREATED ISSUES, OFFERED POLL
REQUESTS AND REVIEWS AND
GENERALLY PARTICIPATED IN THE
KUBERNETES PROJECT ON GITHUB
ALONE.
BEYOND THE SHEER NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WHO ARE PARTICIPATING
PARTICIPATING,
THEIR ENGAGEMENT IS
UNPRECEDENTED.  THOSE 700
COMMUNITY MEMBERS INTERACTED
WITH THE KUBERNETES PROJECT ON
GITHUB AN AVERAGE OF 15 TIMES.
IF MY MATH IS CORRECT, THAT'S
MORE THAN 10,000 EVENTS CHANGING
KUBERNETES IN FEBRUARY IN
GITHUB ALONE.  BEYOND THAT, WE
HAVE SPECIAL INTEREST GROUPS, WE
HAVE MAILING LISTS.  A
CONVERSATION ABOUT GOOGLE'S OPEN
SOURCE COMMITMENTS WOULDN'T BE
COMPLETE WITHOUT A VIEW INTO
ANOTHER HIGHLY VISIBLE OPEN
SOURCE PROJECT.  TENSORFLOW AND
KUBERNETES COMPETE FOR THE TOP
POSITION FOR MOST ENGAGED
PROJECTS MOST MONTHS AND HERE TO
CORRECT ME IF TENSORFLOW IS
LEADING IN MARCH IS OUR SENIOR
FELLOW FROM GOOGLE, JEFF DENY.
DEAN.
[ APPLAUSE ]
Jeff Dean: ALL RIGHT.  THANK
YOU, SARAH.
SO I'M GOING TO TALK TO YOU
ABOUT TENSORFLOW, WHICH IS A
MACHINE LEARNING PLATFORM OUR
GROUP HAS BEEN BUILDING TO HELP
SUPPORT OUR RESEARCH AND TO GET
THE MACHINE LEARNING SYSTEMS
DEPLOYED THROUGHOUT GOOGLE.
SO I LEAD THE GOOGLE BRAIN TEAM,
WHICH IS OUR ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE RESEARCH TEAM IN
MOUNTAIN VIEW AND OUR GROUP DOES
LONG-TERM RESEARCH SO WE NEED A
PLATFORM THAT'S VERY FLEXIBLE
TO ALLOW US TO EXPRESS LOTS OF
DIFFERENT KINDS OF MACHINE
LEARNING IDEAS AND ALSO TO
INTERACT WITH THE MACHINE
LEARNING COMMUNITY.  WE PUBLISH
PAPERS.
SO OUR GROUP BUILT AN EARLIER
SYSTEM CALLED DISBELIEF THAT WE
DID NOT OPEN SOURCE, AND THEN WE
USED THAT FOR A COUPLE OF YEARS
FOR OUR RESEARCH AND FOR SOME
PRODUCT USES, AND THEN AS WE
WERE THINKING ABOUT WHAT WE
WANTED TO DO NEXT, WE TOOK THE
IDEAS THAT WERE GOOD ABOUT
DISBELIEF BUT ALSO FIXED A
BUNCH.  THINGS THAT WE DIDN'T
LIKE ABOUT IT AND CREATED
TENSORFLOW.  AND FROM THE
BEGINNING, I ARGUED THAT WE
SHOULD OPEN SOURCE TENSORFLOW
AND REALLY MAKE IT A COMMON
PLATFORM FOR EVERYONE IN THE
WORLD, NOT JUST PEOPLE WITHIN
GOOGLE.
AND SO BIOPSIESING THIS, WE
ACTUALLY ALLOW LOTS OF PEOPLE TO
BENEFIT FROM MACHINE LEARNING
AND BE ABLE TO USE MACHINE
LEARNING IN THEIR PRODUCTS, AND
TO REALLY CREATE A COMMUNITY
AROUND IT.
SO WHY OPEN SOURCE IT?
ONE OF THE THINGS WE LIKE TO DO
IS PUBLISH RESEARCH PAPERS ABOUT
OUR WORK, AND BIOPSIESING SORT
OF REFERENCE IMPLEMENTATIONS OF
SOME OF THE CODE USED TO CREATE
THE EXPERIMENTS IN THE PAPERS,
WE ALLOW PEOPLE TO MORE EASILY
REPLICATE OUR RESEARCH.  WE ALSO
ALLOW PEOPLE TO TAKE THOSE
IDEAS AND USE THEM IN THEIR SORT
OF PRODUCT APPLICATIONS AND
MACHINE LEARNING, SO THINGS LIKE
COMPUTER VISION MODELS THEY CAN
USE IN A LOT OF DIFFERENT WAYS
IN VARIOUS PRODUCTS, EITHER
RUNNING ON DEVICES OR RUNNING IN
THE CLOUD, AND WE REALLY WANT
TO BRING MACHINE LEARNING TO
EVERYONE.  THERE'S BILLIONS OF
PEOPLE IN THE WORLD, MILLIONS OF
DEVELOPERS, WHO CAN BENEFIT
FROM USING MACHINE LEARNING TO
ACCOMPLISH THINGS THAT ARE HARD
TO ACCOMPLISH OTHER WAYS.
SO HERE'S A GRAPH OF KIND OF THE
INTERNAL SPREAD OF MACHINE
LEARNING IN TENSORFLOW USAGE
WITHIN GOOGLE AND ONE OF THE
THINGS WE DO AS A TEAM IS BUILD
THIS SYSTEM SO THAT EVERYONE CAN
BENEFIT WITHIN GOOGLE AND WE
SPREAD IDEAS, AND AS TEAMS PICK
UP MACHINE LEARNING, OTHER TEAMS
SEE THAT AND SEE THAT IT WOULD
BE APPLICABLE TO THEIR KINDS OF
PROBLEMS.
AND SO YOU SEE IT BEING USED FOR
MANY, MANY DIFFERENT THINGS, AS
THERE'S ABOUT 4,000 DIRECTORIES
NOW THAT CONTAIN TENSORFLOW
CONFIGURATION FILES WITHIN
GOOGLE.  SO IT'S BEING USED BY
HUNDREDS OR EVEN THOUSANDS OF
TEAMS.  IT'S USED IN POPULAR
PRODUCTS LIKE GMAIL AND YouTUBE
AND TRANSLATE, SEARCH.
AND IT'S ALSO -- BECAUSE WE OPEN
SOURCED IT, IT'S NOW THE NUMBER
ONE MACHINE LEARNING REPOSITORY
ON GITHUB AND PEOPLE HAVE
REALLY TAKEN TO IT AS A WAY TO
EXPRESS MACHINE LEARNING IDEAS,
TO USE MACHINE LEARNING CODE IN
THEIR PRODUCTS IN VARIOUS WAYS.
AND JUST TO SHOW YOU WHAT A RIDE
IT'S BEEN SINCE WE OPEN SOURCE
IT, WE OPEN SOURCED IT IN
NOVEMBER 2015 AND THIS IS A
COMPARISON WITH A BUNCH OF OTHER
SORT OF OPEN SOURCED MACHINE
LEARNING PROJECTS, MOST OF WHICH
HAVE BEEN AROUND FOR QUITE A
BIT LONGER.  AND WE HAVE A
PRETTY ENGAGED COMMUNITY AND
THAT'S REALLY VALUABLE TO US
US.  WE'RE GETTING LOTS OF GOOD
FEEDBACK, GETTING LOTS OF
INFORMATION ABOUT, YOU KNOW,
WHAT KINDS OF THINGS WE SHOULD
BE WORKING ON AS A COMMUNITY,
AND I THINK ONE OF THE REASONS
IT'S GONE WELL SO FAR IS THAT
WE'VE CONTINUED TO INNOVATE AND
CREATE NEW AND IMPROVED VERSIONS
OF TENSORFLOW AND ADD FEATURES
THAT PEOPLE REALLY REQUEST, SO
SOME OF   OF -- JUST TO
HIGHLIGHT A FEW, YOU KNOW, EVERY
COUPLE OF MONTHS WE'VE BEEN
DOING MINOR VERSION RELEASE.  WE
JUST HAD OUR 1.0 RELEASE AND WE
RELEASED DISTRIBUTED
TENSORFLOW, WHICH IS THE BIG
REQUESTED FEATURE, ADDED SUPPORT
FOR LOTS OF PLATFORMS EICH iOS
AND MAC AND WINDOWS, WORKED A
LOT OF PERFORMANCE FOR OUR 1.0
RELEASE WHICH WAS LAST MONTH
MONTH.  SO THAT'S BEEN GREAT
GREAT.  AND THE OTHER THING
THAT I THINK IS REALLY
IMPORTANT IS THAT IT RUNS ON
LOTS OF DIFFERENT PLATFORMS.  WE
WANT MACHINE LEARNING TO RUN
WHEREVER IT NEEDS TO BE RUN.
AND THAT INCLUDES CPUs, GPUs, TP
Us, OUR CUSTOM MACHINE LEARNING
CHIPS, ANDROID, iOS, RASPBERRY,
PIE, ALL THESE THINGS ARE
IMPORTANT.  SO HERE TO TELL YOU
MORE ABOUT THE COMMUNITY THAT
WE'VE BUILT UP IS RAJAT MONGA
WHO HEADS UP OUR TENSORFLOW
DEVELOPMENT EFFORTS WITHIN OUR
TEAM.  THANK YOU.
[ APPLAUSE ]
Rajat Monga: THANK YOU, JEFF
JEFF.  SO JEFF TALKED ABOUT A
NUMBER OF THINGS ABOUT
TENSORFLOW.  ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT THINGS WE FEEL ABOUT
ANY OPEN SOURCE PROJECT IS THE
COMMUNITY, AND YOU HEARD A LOT
OF SPEAKERS EARLIER TALK ABOUT
THIS.  SO LET'S LOOK AT THE
GREAT OPEN SOURCE COMMUNITY THAT
WE HAVE.
WITH NEARLY 500 CONTRIBUTORS
FROM OUTSIDE GOOGLE AND MANY
MORE WITHIN GOOGLE AS WELL, AND
NEARLY 15,000 COMMENTS OR
UPDATES TO THE SOURCE CODE OVER
THE LAST YEAR, OR THE LAST 14,
15 MONTHS.  IT'S A VERY ACTIVE
PROJECT.  THERE'S LOTS OF GOING
ON, LOTS OF DEVELOPMENT.  IT'S
ONE OF THE MOST ACTIVE PROJECTS
OUT THERE.
WE ENGAGE DIRECTLY WITH THE
COMMUNITY.  WE LOOK AT THE STACK
WEAR FLOW.  WE HAVE OVER 5,000
QUESTIONS THAT HAVE BEEN
ANSWERED BY US AND THE COMMUNITY
ITSELF.  AND OVER A HUNDRED NEW
COMMUNITIES SUBMITTED ISSUES
THAT RESPONDED TO THAT ARE FIXED
EVERY SINGLE WEEK.  IT'S BEING
USED VERY WIDELY IN ACADEMIA SO,
YOU KNOW, SOME OF THE TOP
UNIVERSITIES ARE USING IT FOR
THEIR MACHINE LEARNING COURSES.
IN FACT, STANFORD JUST OFFERED
A COURSE SPECIFICALLY TO TRAIN
THEIR STUDENTS ON TENSORFLOW SO
THEY COULD USE IT FOR ALL KINDS
OF MACHINE LEARNING WORK.
JEFF SHARED SOME OF THIS.  THERE
ARE MANY DIFFERENT PRODUCTS AT
GOOGLE THAT USE TENSORFLOW NOW.
THIS IS JUST SOME OF THEM.  SO
YOUTUBE USES IT FOR
RECOMMENDATIONS.  GMAIL USES IT
FOR SPAM.  IT'S PART OF THE
CLOUD PLATFORM FOR THE MACHINE
LEARNING ITSELF, AND MANY OTHER
USES, RIGHT.  BUT OPEN SOURCE
WAS NOT JUST FOR GOOGLE, REALLY.
WITH THAT, WE'VE MADE IT
AVAILABLE TO MANY COMPANIES OUT
THERE AND    AND, AGAIN, THIS IS
A SMALL LIST OF COMPANIES THAT
ARE USING IT TODAY.
MANY OF THESE ARE BUILDING
PRODUCTS FOR USERS LIKE YOURSELF
OR MANY OTHERS OUT THERE.
IT DOESN'T STOP AT THESE LARGE
COMPANIES, THOUGH.
MACHINE LEARNING IS REALLY FOR
EVERYONE, AND THERE ARE MANY
PEOPLE OUT THERE WHO ARE JUST
OBVIOUS OR TRYING IT OUT OR
TRYING TO SOLVE REAL PROBLEMS
AND THIS MAKES IT POSSIBLE FOR
THEM TO DO IT.  LET'S TAKE A
LOOK AT A FEW EXAMPLES OF WHAT
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN DOING WITH
TENSORFLOW.
SO YOU MIGHT HAVE SEEN THIS
DEMO OUT THERE FOR CUCUMBER.
THERE IS A CUCUMBER -- ONCE YOU
HAVE THE CUCUMBERS YOU NEED TO
SORT THEM BY SIZE OR SHAPE.
THIS USED TO BE MANUAL WORK,
ROUGHLY EIGHT HOURS A DAY,
MOSTLY DONE BY THE MOTHERS OUT
THERE.  THE SON DECIDED LET'S
SEE IF WE CAN AUTOMATE SOME OF
THIS.  HE TOOK A WHOLE BUNCH OF
PICTURES OF THESE CUCUMBERS,
DOWNLOADED INTO TENSORFLOW.
TRAINED THE MODEL TO IDENTIFY
AND SORT THEM AND THEN RAN
IT ON AND CONNECTED IT AND
AUTOMATED THAT WHOLE PROCESS ALL
BY ITSELF.  PRETTY AMAZING USE
OF TENSORFLOW.
[ APPLAUSE ]
THANK YOU.
MACHINE LEARNING IS BECOMING
VERY IMPORTANT FOR HEALTHCARE.
AND HERE I JUST WANTED TO MAKE
SURE A COUPLE OF EXAMPLES HOW
IT'S BEEN USED IN HEALTHCARE.
SO THE ONE ON THE LEFT IS AN
ARTICLE FOR SOMETHING THAT WAS
DONE AT STANFORD BY STUDENTS
THERE WHO COLLECTED A WHOLE
BUNCH OF PICTURES ABOUT SKIN
LESIONS WHICH SEPARATED THEM
FROM, OKAY, THESE ARE CANCEROUS,
THESE ARE NOT, TRAINED A NEURAL
NETWORK TO IDENTIFY FROM THAT
WHICH ONES ARE CANCEROUS.  THEY
HAVE A MODEL THAT IS AS GREAT AS
DERMATOLOGISTS WHICH CAN BE
GREAT FOR USERS.  ANOTHER
EXAMPLE IS IN OUR TEAM WE LOOKED
AT PICTURES OF THE EYE, THE
IMAGES YOU SEE ON THE RIGHT AND
AGAIN TRYING TO IDENTIFY IF A
USER HAS D OR NOT
DIABETIC RECEIPT NONE PATH
THINK OR NOT.  IF YOU SEE HOW
MANY THERE IS THERE ARE IN THE
WORLD AND HOW MANY PATIENTS, WE
DON'T HAVE ENOUGH DOCTORS TO
REACH EVERY PATIENT.  THIS IS A
GREAT WAY THAT MACHINE LEARNING
CAN REALLY HELP PEOPLE WHO HAVE
NO CHANCE OF GETTING ACCESS TO
DOCTORS TODAY.
[ APPLAUSE
]
THANK YOU.
Sarah Novotny: THANKS, JEFF AND
RAJAT.  I HAVE TO SAY, YOUR
COMMUNITY HAS DONE SOME AMAZING
THINGS I WOULD NEVER HAVE
EXPECTED WITH THE TENSORFLOW
PLATFORM.  CUCUMBERS?
THE CREATIVITY IS ONE OF MY
FAVORITE SECOND-ORDER EFFECTS OF
OPEN DEVELOPMENTS AND OPEN
COMMUNITIES.  OPEN DEVELOPMENT
IS BOTH A BENEFIT AND A
RESPONSIBILITY WITH A TIGHT
FEEDBACK LOOP.
I MENTIONED THAT OPEN
DEVELOPMENT AND A COMMITMENT TO
OPEN SOURCE IS ALSO A DRAW TO
GOOD DEVELOPERS.  I COUNT OUR
NEW VP, SAM RAMJI, AMONG THOSE
WHO WERE DRAWN TO GOOGLE BECAUSE
OF A COMMITMENT TO OPENNESS.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN WELCOMING THE
FORMER CEO OF APIGEE AND CLOUD
FOUNDRY FOUNDATION HERE TO SHARE
HIS VISION ON OPEN DEVELOPMENT,
SAM RAMJI.
[ APPLAUSE ]
Sam Ramji: ALL RIGHT.  HOW ARE
WE DOING SO FAR?
[ APPLAUSE ]
PRETTY AWESOME?  NOT TOTALLY
SURE WHAT I'M DOING ON THE SAME
STAGE AS THE INVENTOR OF THE
INTERNET, INVENTOR OF
KUBERNETES, AND INVENTOR OF
TENSORFLOW.  BUT I THOUGHT I
WOULD TALK ABOUT HOW GOOGLE
THINKS ABOUT OPENNESS.  WE THINK
THIS IS THE BEST TIME IN
HISTORY TO BE A DEVELOPER.  OUR
CRAFT IS RESPECTED.  OUR WORK
HAS BEEN ELEVATED, AND WE'RE IN
AN ERA OF RISING DEMAND.  THIS
IS OUR TIME.  NOW, AS COMPANIES
REALIZE THEY HAVE TO BECOME
DIGITAL BUSINESSES, THEY HAVE
FIGURED OUT THAT THIS
TRANSFORMATION IS POWERED BY
DEVELOPERS.  SO AS MUCH AS THIS
IS OUR TIME, THE STAKES ARE
HIGH.  WE HAVE RESPONSIBILITIES
TO OUR CRAFT, TO EACH OTHER, AND
TO THE WORLD THE DEVELOPERS
NEVER HAD BEFORE.
HIGH AMONG THEM IS THE NEED TO
CREATE SYSTEMS THAT ARE SECURE,
FLEXIBLE AND OPEN.  LATE LAST
YEAR I CAME TO GOOGLE CLOUD
BECAUSE I FELT THERE WAS NO
BETTER WAY, NO BETTER PLACE TO
MAKE REAL ALL THE GOOD THAT OPEN
SOURCE PROMISES AND IN A WAY TO
IMPACT ALL THE PLACES SOFTWARE
IS GOING WITH WHAT WE CALL THE
OPEN CLOUD.  OUR TOOLS, YOUR
TOOLS, YOUR SYSTEMS HAVE TO MAKE
SENSE.  THEY HAVE TO BE
CONNECTED TO BE EFFICIENT.  THEY
HAVE TO BE OPEN SO WE CAN SHAPE
THEM HOW WE NEED THEM TO BE.
WE CAN CREATE THE AGE OF OPEN
DEVELOPMENT.
NOW, OPEN DEVELOPMENT DEMANDS
OPENNESS IN EVERY DIMENSION.
OPEN APIs, OPEN SOURCE, AND OPEN
CLOUDS.  WHEN WE HAVE ACCESS TO
EVERY PART OF OUR TECHNOLOGY
ENVIRONMENT, WE CAN BUILD A
SYSTEM WE REQUIRE TO DEVELOP AT
THE SPEED WE NEED.  OPENNESS
LETS US MAKE UNEXPECTED
COMBINATIONS.  SO, FOR EXAMPLE,
BOTH CLOUD FOUNDRY FOUNDATION
AND KUBERNETES ARE INSPIRED BY
GOOGLE'S BORG.  AND WE STARTED
TO SEE THESE COMMUNITIES COME
TOGETHER AROUND A PROJECT CALLED
THE OPEN BROKE ER API WHICH
ACLOUDS CLOUD FOUNDRY AND
KUBERNETES CALL EACH OTHER.
RECENTLY USERS WHO HAVE DEEP
INVESTMENTS IN CLOUD FOUNDRY
ASKED FOR A WAY TO RUN
KUBERNETES ON TOP OF BOSH.
THAT'S TOOLING THEY ARE WILL BE
COMFORTABLE WITH THAT SITS UNDER
CF.  ENGINEERS FROM PIVOTAL AND
GOOGLE TOOK THIS TO HEART, AND
MAKE THE NECESSARY UPDATES TO
BOSH.  THIS NEW TOOL SET IS
PACKAGED AS KUBO, KUBERNETES ON
BOSH.  AND TODAY KUBO IS OPEN.
IT'S PREALPHA OPEN SOURCE ON
GITHUB AVAILABLE TODAY.
I EXPECT MORE CLOUD FOUNDRY
INSTALLATIONS WILL LOOK TO ADD
KUBERNETES TO THEIR
ENVIRONMENTS.  TO QUOTE SARAH
NOVOTNY, THIS IS COMPOSABLE
INFRASTRUCTURE AT ITS FINEST.
APPLICATIONS WRITTEN WITH OPEN
PREMISE HELP US HOWEVER MUCH IS
POSSIBLE, REASON ABOUT, AND
FUTURE PROOF OUR APPLICATIONS.
THINK ABOUT THIS.  EVERY DAY
CRITICAL INFORMATION AND LOGIC
IS ACCESSED FROM AND POURED INTO
A WIDE VARIETY OF LEGACY
SYSTEMS, BUILT YEARS AGO USING
PROPRIETARY PROTOCOLS.  THEY
WEREN'T ALL FOLLOWING VINT
CERF'S ADVICE, TO START OPEN AND
STAY OPEN.
SO WHATEVER WE BUILD TODAY IS
ACTUALLY TOMORROW'S LEGACY.  ONE
OF MY FAVORITE JOB TITLES I
HAVE EVER READ IS IN A BOOK
CALLED "A FIRE UPON THE DEEP."
ANYBODY READ "A FIRE UPON THE
DEEP," VERNOR VINGE, BRILLIANT
BOOK.  RECOMMENDED TO ME BY
JEREMY ALLISON WHO IS THE
MAINTAINER OF SAMBA.  IT'S SET
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF YEARS FROM
NOW AND THE STORY IS BUILT ON
INTERSTELLAR TRAVEL BUT WITHOUT
BREAKING LIGHT SLEEP.  THESE
SHIPS ARE MASSIVELY AUTOMATED ON
NEW SOFTWARE AND NEW SOFTWARE
IS CONSTANTLY BEING WRITTEN TO
SOLVE NEW PROBLEMS.  FOR THE
REALLY OLD PROBLEMS, THE BORING
PROBLEMS LIKE CORE LIFE SUPPORT
SYSTEMS, THEY HAVE REALLY OLD
SOFTWARE.  WHAT'S THE JOB TITLE,
PROGRAMMER-ARC KEYOLOGIST.
THERE'S ALSO AN ELEMENT HERE OF
SOFTWARE AS ORAL HISTORY, TO
QUOTE JAMES GOVERNOR, AND WE
NEED TO KEEP SHARING IDEAS ABOUT
THE CODE WE WRITE AS MUCH AS WE
SHARE THE CODE WE WRITE.  SO WE
HAVE ALIBLE BUT OLD
APPLICATIONS STOMACH ON OLD
HARDWARE.  WE HAVE NEW AND
FUTURE LEGACIES WE RUN ON
ELASTIC PLATFORMS LIKE
KUBERNETES AND GOOGLE CLOUD.
AND WE HAVE DATA THAT DRIVES
THOSE APPLICATIONS AND RESULTS
FROM THOSE APPLICATIONS, BOTH
INPUT AND OUTPUT.  GENERALLY
THAT DATA IS WHEREVER THE
APPLICATIONS ARE AND SHARES THE
SAME CONSTRAINTS.  WE ALSO HAVE
NEW MODES OF COMPUTING THAT ARE
FAR FROM THE DESKTOP, EVEN
MOBILE CLIENTS IN THE APPS ON
THOSE ARE STARTING TO LOOK LIKE
OLD HAT.  WE'RE GETTING DATA
FROM LIGHT BULBS.  WE ARE
RUNNING APPS ON OIL RIGS AND IN
SURGERY CENTERS.  WE ARE TRYING
TO MAKE SENSE OF ALL OF IT WITH
ANALYTICS.  FOR THE REALLY HARD
ANALYSIS PROBLEMS WE ARE USING
MACHINE LEARNING.  NOW I
GRADUATED IN 1994 WITH A DEGREE
FOCUSED ON AI AND NEUROSCIENCE.
IF YOU SAID AI BACK THEN YOU
WENT TO THE BACK OF THE HIRING
QUEUE MUCH IT WAS THE AI WINTER.
FOR ARE A WHILE WE CONCEALED
IT UNDER THE SAFER HEADING OF
MACHINE LEARNING.  AS FEI FEI LI
SAID ON WEDNESDAY, THE AI
WINTER IS OPEN AND IT'S TIME FOR
THE DEMOCRATIZATION OF AI.
LONG LIVE AI!
[ APPLAUSE ]
SO FINALLY WE'VE GOT THE PRODUCT
MANAGERS, THE MARKETING
MANAGERS AND THE ANALYSTS WHO
ARE ALL TRYING TO FIGURE OUT IF
THIS THING IS WORKING THE IS
THIS JUST TECHNOLOGY OR IS THIS
REALLY BUSINESS?  YOU KNOW, THE
PROOF AS THEY SAY IS IN THE
SPREADSHEET.  SO WE EVEN NEED TO
MAKE THESE SYSTEMS OPEN TO
SPREADSHEETS SO WE CAN BRING
THOSE USERS ON BOARD BECAUSE
BUSINESS USERS MATTER, TOO.
OPEN DEVELOPMENT IS THE PATTERN
WE SEE EVERYONE HEADING TOWARDS.
IT'S MADE OUT OF OPEN APIs,
OPEN SOURCE, AND OPEN CLOUDS.
APIs ARE EVERYWHERE.  WE USE
THEM TO GET TO MODERN SERVICES
LIKE 18-WHEELER YES AND
BIGQUERY.  WE ROLL OUR OWN OVER
MICROSERVICES AND WE WRAP THEM
AROUND LEGACY SYSTEMS LIKE
GENERAL IMAGINE LETTERS AND MAIN
FRAMES.  THEY HAVE TO BE OPENED
DOCUMENTED LIKE USING STARRED
LIKE THE OPENAPI SPEC.  THEY
HAVE TO USE OPEN PROTOCOLS LIKE
HTTP AND gRPC.  THEY HAVE TO USE
JSON BUT TIMES XML.  OPEN APIs
HAVE TO BE ABLE TO BE CALLED
FROM NAIROBI, NOT JUST BY CODE
RUNNING IN THE APIs PROVIDERS
CLOUD.  YOU SHOULD BE ABLE TO
CALL THAT ANYWHERE IN CASE YOU
HAVE TO MOVE YOUR WORKLOAD
LATER.  IF YOU ARE LOOKING FOR
THE BIG ANGLE, MARSHAL VAN
ALSTYNE HAVE DEMONSTRATED THAT
APIs GROW FASTER AND ARE MORE
PROFITABLE.  SO OPEN SOURCE IS A
MODERN DEVELOPERS BASIC
EXPECTATION AND THE DEFAULT
LICENSING MODEL FOR NEARLY ALL
MODERN DEVELOPMENT TOOLS.  OPEN
SOURCE IS A POSITIVE-SUM GAME
WHERE NO ONE NEEDS TO LOSE IN
ORDER FOR SOMEONE ELSE TO WIN.
AS ERIC, JEFF, AND RAJAT SHOWED,
AT GOOGLE WE BELIEVE IN
OFFERING TECHNICAL IDEAS LIKE
OPEN ORS, LIKE ANGULAR, ANDROID,
V8, G, gRPC, APACHE BEAM,
KUBERNETES, AND TENSORFLOW.  AND
REALLY IMPORTANT WE BELIEVE IN
GETTING BACK TO OPEN SOURCE
PROJECTS WHERE WE HAVE SOMETHING
TO CONTRIBUTE AND WHERE WE HAVE
RECEIVED SO MUCH VALUE, LIKE
LINUX, KVM, MySQL, PYTHON,
APACHE, ECLIPSE, NODE.JS, SAMBA
AND MANY OTHERS.
ADDITIONALLY, WE GIVE
OPPORTUNITIES TO HIGH SCHOOL AND
COLLEGE STUDENTS EVERY WE ARE
TO BUILD OPEN SOURCE PROJECTS
WHILE BEING MENTORED BY OPEN
SOURCE DEVELOPERS AND LUMINARIES
IN TWO PROGRAMS, GOOGLE SUMMER
OF CODE AND GOOGLE CODE IN.
THIS IS, TO QUOTE JIM ZEMLIN,
THE NEW NORMAL, OPEN SOURCE.
ALL TOGETHER, THIS IS WHAT WE
NEED FOR OPEN DEVELOPMENT.
NOW, WHEN I MET BRIAN STEVENS
LAST YEAR, THE THING HE SAID
THAT MADE ME STOP AND
FUNDAMENTALLY REASSESS GOOGLE'S
CLOUD WAS THE SIMPLE STATEMENT:
WE ARE BUILDING AN OPEN CLOUD.
THAT'S OUR STRATEGY.  I WAS
KIND OF STUNNED.  I HAD TO DIG
DEEPER, AND YOU CAN SEE WHERE MY
EXPLORATION LED ME.  IN BEHIND
SIGHT, I REALLY SHOULDN'T HAVE
BEEN SURPRISED BECAUSE BRIAN
SPENT 14 YEARS AT DEC BUILDING
OPEN SYSTEMS AND 14 YEARS AT RED
HAT MAKING OPEN SOURCE THE
STANDARD.  OWN ARE THE NEW IDEA.
IF WE ARE DOING OPEN
DEVELOPMENT ON OPEN APIs AND
OPEN SOURCE, SHOULD WE WANT AN
OPEN CLOUD?  SIX YEARS AGO AT
OSCON IN 2011, I AND SEVERAL
OTHER PEOPLE STARTED A
NON-PROFIT CALLED THE OPEN CLOUD
INITIATIVE.  WE COULD SEE THE
COMING ERA OF CLOUD OF COMPUTING
BRINGING A PANDORA'S BOX OF
EXCLUDE AND LOCK-IN AND THAT THE
OPEN SOURCE DEFINITION DIDN'T
GUIDE THE CLOUD.  THE NON-PROFIT
WOUND DOWN BUT THED IN LIVE ON.
USERS WIN IN AN OPEN CLOUD.
SO AN OPEN CLOUD IS OPEN SOURCE
FRIENDLY.  IT'S BOTH ACCEPTING
OPEN SOURCE AND GIVING BACK TO
IT.  WE AIM TO BE THE BEST PLACE
TO RUN OPEN SOURCE STACKS.
WE'RE CONTRIBUTING OPEN SOURCE
CLOUD COMPUTING PROJECTS
INCLUDING CORE TECHNOLOGIES LIKE
KUBERNETES AND TENSORFLOW AND
WORKING WITH DOCKER, CLOUD
FOUNDRY AND OPENSTACK.  WE THINK
CHRIS WRIGHT AND RED HAT TEAM
FOR HELPING US SEEING THE VALUE
IN COLLABORATIVELY DEVELOPING
KUBERNETES.  OPEN CLOUD SUPPORTS
OPEN ACCESS WITH NO BARRIERS TO
ENTRY OR EXIT.  SHOULD SHOULD
BE ABLE TO BRING VMS, CONTAINER,
RUNTIME AND FRAMEWORK AND TAKE
YOUR THINGS OUT LIKE DODGER
CONTAINER AND YAML FILES AND
DATABASES.  YOU SHOULD BE ABLE
TO SIGN IN WITH OAUTH.  YOU
SHOULD BE ABLE TO SEE THE LOGS
OF EVERYTHING THAT'S HAPPENS,
ACCESS TRANSPARENCY IS CRUCIAL.
FINALLY AN OPEN CLOUD IS OPEN
TO AN OPEN ECOSYSTEM, PLUGGING
THE PLATFORM DEVELOPER COMMUNITY
DIRECTLY INTO THE PROVIDERS OF
ALL KINDS OF SERVICES.  NOW, LET
ME PAUSE HERE.  THIS IS
IMPORTANT.  SO SERVICES BUILT BY
COMMUNITIES AND COMPANIES
SHOULD GET ALL THE SAME
REPRESENTATION AND DISTRIBUTION
AS SERVICES BUILT BY THE CLOUD
PROVIDE ER.  OPEN INNOVATION
MEANS OPEN TO A WORLD OF IDEAS
AND NOT ASSUMING THAT OUR
IMPLEMENTATION OF CASSANDRA OR
PROVES        POSTGRES IS THE
BEST POSSIBLE ONE.  THERE'S AN
IDEA IN HERE THAT COULD
DEMOCRATIZE SOFTWARE THE WAY
SMARTPHONES DEMOCRATIZED
CONSUMER APPLICATIONS.  MORE
SERVICES, EACH EXCELLENT,
SMALLER IN SCOPE, BUILT
PROFITABLY BY SMALLER TEAMS.
SO I THINK IF WE WORK ON THIS
TOGETHER, WE CAN GET THE
SOFTWARE INDUSTRY TO SOMETHING
SLEEK, ADAPTABLE, AND SUSTAIN
ABLE.  FINALLY, DEVELOPERS ARE
TRYING ALL OF THESE THINGS
TOGETHER INTO THE SYSTEMS THEY
NEED TO WORK AT SPEEDS, SYSTEMS
OF CONTINUOUS INTEGRATION, AND
CONTINUOUS DEPLOYMENT.  IT'S THE
ONRAMP TO EVERYTHING GOOD IN
MODERN SOFTWARE DEVELOPMENT.
DEVELOPERS TAKING RESPONSIBLE
FOR TESTING AND PRODUCTION.  IT
GOES WITHOUT SAYING THAT THEY
ARE USING OPENS LIKE CHEF,
ANSIBLE, PUPPET, SALT, CLOUD
FOUNDRY, GITLAB, JENKINS,
CONCOURSE AND SPINNAKER.  THIS
IS A CONCOURSE SCREEN SHOT.
TODAY THESE SYSTEMS ARE UNIQUE
TO EACH ENTERPRISE.  THEY ARE AS
UNIQUE AS YOUR NERVOUS SYSTEM
AND OFTEN UNIQUE TO EACH
DEVELOPMENT TEAM.  WE COULD SEE
COMMON PATTERNS EMERGE THAT WE
CAN SIMPLIFY AND STANDARDIZE.
AT GOOGLE WE WANT EVERYBODY TO
BENEFIT FROM AN OPEN CLOUD.
TODAY WE ARE ANNOUNCING AN
EXPANSION OF OUR GOOGLE CLOUD
PLATFORM FREE OFFERINGS.  SO
FIRST YOUR CREDITS WILL LAST FOR
A YEAR.
[ APPLAUSE ]
SECOND, WE WILL HAVE A LEVEL OF
COMPUTE, STORAGE, MESSAGING AND
SERVER THAT     LESS THAT WILL
ALWAYS BE FREE.
[ APPLAUSE ]
BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY, WE ARE
WALKING OUR TALK ABOUT THE OPEN
ECOSYSTEM.  YOU CAN SPEND YOUR
CREDITS ON OUR ECOSYSTEM
PARTNERS THROUGH THE GOOGLE
CLOUD LAUNCHER.  WE WILL PAY
DEVELOPERS WHO BUILT THESE
SERVICES FOR YOUR TRIAL
EXPERIENCE BECAUSE YOUR PLATFORM
IS OUR WHOLE ECOSYSTEM.  THIS
IS WHAT OPEN DEVELOPMENT LOOKS
LIKE TO US.
[ APPLAUSE ]
SO OPENAPIs, OPEN SOURCE, AND
OPEN CLOUD.  WE BELIEVE IN OPEN
COLLABORATION WORKING ENGINEER
TO ENGINEER.  WE ARE MOVING FROM
JUST WRITING PAPERS FROM BORG
AND BIG TABLE TO SHARING THE
CODE.  WE ARE WRITING BOOKS ON
SYSTEMS RELIABILITY ENGINEERING
AND WE WANT TO MOVE THE
STATE-OF-THE-ART FORWARD IN BOTH
DEVELOPMENT AND OPERATIONS
WHICH TOGETHER MAKE UP THE
DISCIPLINE OF ENGINEERING.
WE'RE DEPLOYING OUR ENGINEERS TO
WORK DIRECTLY WITH YOU ON YOUR
CRITICAL PROJECTS.  SO WE EXPECT
YOU TO HOLD US ACCOUNTABLE TO
THIS VISION.  LET ME MAKE A
POINT.  NEGATIVE FEEDBACK IS A
GIFT.  IT'S A DECLARATION OF
WHAT'S MISSING, LIKE NEGATIVE
SPACE.  IT SAYS, THIS IS
MISSING.  BUT IF PLATFORM HAD
THIS, IT WOULD BE AWESOME.  SO
LET ME CLOSE BY SAYING, WE'RE
GLAD YOU'RE HERE.  I'M GLAD
YOU'RE HERE.  LET'S BUILD GREAT
THINGS.
THANK YOU.
[ APPLAUSE ]
SO IT'S MY GREAT PLEASURE TO
WELCOME MY FRIEND AND COLLEAGUE
ALISON WAGONFELD.  SHE'S THE
CHIEF MARKETING OFFICER OF
GOOGLE CLOUD AND ONE OF THE
AWESOME PARTS OF MY JOB IS I GET
TO WORK WITH ALISON EVERY DAY.
PLEASE WELCOME ALISON.
[ APPLAUSE ]
Alison Wagonfeld: THANK YOU.
THAT WAS AWESOME.
GOOD MORNING.  WELCOME.  THANK
YOU FOR BEING HERE.  I'M HUMBLED
AND PRIVILEGED TO BE ABLE TO
BRING TO MARKET THE INCREDIBLE
TECHNOLOGY THAT MY COLLEAGUES
AND OTHERS HAVE BEEN BUILDING
OVER DECADES, BUILDING WITH THE
OPEN CLOUD COMMUNITY.
WE'RE NOW GOING TO TRANSITION TO
THE SECOND PART OF OUR PROGRAM
THIS MORNING WHERE WE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HEAR FROM THREE
GREAT START-UPS THAT ARE DOING
REALLY INTERESTING WORK,
ENGAGING WITH THE COMMUNITY IN
BUILDING A GOOGLE CLOUD AND WITH
GOOGLE CLOUD.  FIRST, WE'LL
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO HEAR
FROM WILL MARSHALL, FOUNDER AND
CEO OF PLANET DOING INCREDIBLE
WORK USING AT LIGHT IMAGERY.
SECOND, WE WILL HEAR FROM WILLEM
SUNDBLAD, FROM ODEN
TECHNOLOGIES.  ESTRINS FORMING
THE DEMOCRATIZATION OF AI.  AND,
THIRD, HER MAN, THE CEO OF
IMPROBABLE WILL SHARE GREAT WORK
THEY'RE DOING.  IT'S A
LONDON-BASED COMPANY WITH
SIMULATIONS AND GAMING IN
VIRTUAL WORLDS.  SO NOW PLEASE
JOIN ME IN WELCOMING WILL TO THE
STAGE.
[ APPLAUSE ]
Will Marshall: GOOD MORNING.  MY
NAME IS WILL MARSHALL.  I'M THE
CEO AND CO-FOUNDER OF PLANET.
AND PLANET'S MISSION IS TO IMAGE
EVERY POINT ON THE EARTH'S
SURFACE AND MAKE CHANGE VISIBLE,
ACCESSIBLE, AND ACTIONABLE.  WE
DO THIS WITH A NETWORK OF OVER
A HUNDRED SATELLITES THAT WE'VE
DESIGNED, BUILT, AND OPERATE IN
SPACE TODAY.  IN FACT, TODAY
PLANET OPERATES THE LARGEST
FLEET OF SATELLITES IN HUMAN
HISTORY.
UNLIKE TRADITIONAL SATELLITES,
OURS ARE MUCH SMALLER.  AND, IN
FACT, WE'VE BUILT 13 DIFFERENT
ITERATIONS OF THESE SATELLITES
AND LAUNCHED THEM ON 13
DIFFERENT ROCKETS OVER THE LAST
FEW YEARS TO CONSTANTLY IMPROVE
OUR CAPABILITY IN SPACE.  WE
CALL THIS AGILE AEROSPACE.
AND A FEW WEEKS AGO, WE LAUNCHED
OUR LATEST FLEET OF 88
SATELLITES ON THIS ROCKET.
IT'S THE LARGEST NUMBER OF
SATELLITES EVER DEPLOYED FROM A
ROCKET IN HUMAN HISTORY.  IT WAS
PRETTY NERVE-RACKING.  BUT
FRICKING COOL.
[ APPLAUSE ]
THANK YOU.
SO AS COOL AS SPACE SUFFICIENT
IS AND I COULD GEEK OUT ALL DAY,
THAT'S NOT WHAT I'M HERE TO
TALK ABOUT.  YOU SEE, THE
SATELLITES FOR US ARE A
BACK-END.  WHAT THEY ENABLE IS
WHAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT AND
THAT'S THE DATA THAT THEY CAN
PRODUCE.  AND PARTICULARLY THE
IMAGERY.
SEE, TRADITIONAL SATELLITE
IMAGERY YOU FIND ONLINE IS OLD.
AND WITH THE 149 SATELLITES
THAT WE OPERATE TODAY IN SPACE,
WE HAVE THE CAPACITY TO IMAGE
EVERY POINT ON THE LAND AREA OF
THE EARTH EVERY SINGLE DAY AND
SEE CHANGE AS IT HAPPENS.
WE SEE EVERY PORT, EVERY CITY,
EVERY FARM, EVERY FOREST ACROSS
THE WHOLE EARTH EVERY DAY.
AND AT THE HIGHEST LEVEL, THIS
IS USED FOR MANY THINGS BUT THE
HIGHEST LEVEL IT'S USEFUL FOR US
TO TAKE CARE OF OUR CHANGING
PLANET.
HERE ARE A COUPLE OF IMAGES SO
YOU GET A SENSE FOR WHAT WE CAN
SEE.  EARS AN OIL REFINERY.  YOU
CAN SEE SHIPS      SHIPS.  YOU
CAN SEE ROADS.  YOU CAN SEE
BUILDINGS.  YOU CAN SEE
INDIVIDUAL TREES.  HERE YOU CAN
SEE ANOTHER PORT AREA.  YOU CAN
JUST ABOUT SEE VEHICLES AND
ROADS.  BUT YOU CAN'T SEE PEOPLE
OR READ NUMBER PLATES
PLATES.  THIS IS ABOUT WIDE-
WIDE-SCALE CHANGE.  BUT OUR
CAPABILITY IS BEING ENHANCED
BECAUSE WE RECENTLY ANNOUNCED
THAT WE'RE GOING TO BE ACQUIRING
TERRA BELLA, GOOGLE'S SATELLITE
ARM, IN WHICH -- WITH WHICH WE
WILL BE GAINING 7, AND SOON 13,
HIGH-RESOLUTION SATELLITES IN
ORBIT TO COMPLEMENT THIS, AND,
IN FACT, THE SATELLITES
SATELLITES, THE MEDIUM
RES AND THE HI RES IS VERY
COMPLEMENTARY.  SO WHAT DOES
THIS ALL MEAN?  WELL, FOR ONE
THING, IT MEANS A SHARED TON OF
DATA, AND IT DRAMATICALLY
INCREASING AMOUNTS EVERY SINGLE
DAY.  TERABYTES COMING DOWN
DOCUMENTING CHANGES AROUND OUR
PLANET.
AND WE NEED TO GET THIS DATA
QUICKLY AND RELY IABLY TO OUR
USERS, AND SO YESTERDAY WE WERE
PLEASED TO ANNOUNCE THAT WE HAVE
SWITCHED TO GOOGLE CLOUD TO
HOST OUR IMAGERY AND DO OUR DATA
PROCESSING.
[ APPLAUSE ]
AND WHILST THERE'S A HANDFUL OF
COMPANIES THAT CAN OFFER STORAGE
AND PROCESSING WE WERE REALLY
IMPRESSED BY GOOGLE CLOUD'S CORE
TECHNOLOGY, ESPECIALLY THE
MACHINE LEARNING TRAJECTORY IN
BOTH HARDWARE AND SOFTWARE THAT
WE THINK WILL BE VERY USEFUL, AS
WELL AS THE DEEP UNDERSTANDING
OF GEOSPATIAL DATA AND I WOULD
LIKE TO THANK THE SENIOR
LEADERSHIP TEAM AT GOOGLE CLOUD
AS WELL AS, IN PARTICULAR, DIANE
GREENE, FOR WORKING WITH US.
BUT THIS LEADS TO AN IMPORTANT
ANNOUNCEMENT TODAY      TODAY.
YOU SEE AT PLANET, WE BELIEVE
OUR IMAGERY SHOULD BE AVAILABLE
TO EVERYONE.  NOT JUST THE BIG
COMPANIES AND GOVERNMENTS THAT
HAVE ACCESSED SATELLITE IMAGERY
TO DATE AND SO --
[ APPLAUSE ]
IF WE CAN ADVANCE THE SLIDE....
THAT'S WHY I'M EXCITED TODAY
TO ANNOUNCE THE RELEASE OF
PLANET EXPLORER BETA.  WE WANT
TO GET DATA INTO THE HANDS OF
INDIVIDUALS, SMALL AND MEDIUM-
SIZED BUSINESSES, NGOs,
DEVELOPERS, RESEARCHERS AROUND
THE PLANET.
PLANET EXPLORER BETA IS THE
FIRST GLOBAL PLATFORM UPDATED
EVERY MONTH WITH IMAGERY OF THE
ENTIRE PLANET       PLANET.  NO
LOGIN REQUIRED.
PLANET EXPLORER ENABLES THE
THE -- US TO SEE THE TIME
ELEMENT TO SATELLITE IMAGERY
IMAGERY.  LET ME SHOW YOU
HOW IT WORKS.
ANYONE WHO GOES TO PLANET
PLANET.COM CAN VIEW OUR IMAGES
ON A MONTHLY AND QUARTERLY
BASIS.  EACH GLOBAL BASE MAP IS
MADE UP OF MILLIONS -- LITERALLY
MILLIONS -- OF INDIVIDUAL
ESCALATE IMAGERY IES THAT WE'VE
SWITCHED TOGETHER.  USING THE
TIME LINE, YOU CAN NAVIGATE
QUICKLY ACROSS THE WORLD IN
SPACE AND IN TIME.  TO DATE,
SATELLITE MAPS HAVE BEEN STATIC
AND WE'VE CHANGED THAT.  PLANET
HAS ADDED THE TIME AXIS TO MAPS.
THAT'S THE KEY DIFFERENCE.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT GILROY IN
CALIFORNIA, ZOOM IN AND SEE A
LITTLE BIT CLOSER WHAT YOU CAN
SEE.
SO IF WE ZOOM IN HERE, WHEN YOU
ZOOM IN YOU CAN SEE CHANGES ON A
MUCH MORE GRANULAR LEVEL.  YOU
CAN YOU CAN SEE IN THIS CASE THE
FIELDS CHANGING WITH THE
VARIOUS HARVESTING PROCESSES IN
THESE FIELDS.  BUT THERE'S MORE.
ONCE YOU LOG IN AND YOU CAN DO
SO WITH A FREE ACCOUNT, YOU CAN
SEE A FULL SET OF IMAGERY.  WE
HAVE TAKEN IMAGERY -- ONE
SECOND.  WE'VE TAKEN, ON AVERAGE
, MORE THAN 150 IMAGES OF EVERY
POINT ON THE LAND AREA OF THE
EARTH'S SURFACE AND YOU CAN
BROWSE THIS FULL STACK OF
IMAGERY WITH A FREE ACCOUNT.'  .
YOU CAN SEE THOSE NEW IMAGES
AS THEY COME DOWN DAY BY DAY,
AND YOU CAN COMPARE CHANGES AS
THEY HAPPEN WITH A CHANGE TOOL
THAT ALLOWS YOU TO SEE CHANGES
AS THEY HAPPEN DAY BY DAY.  LIKE
IN GILROY, SEEING THE CHANGES
IN THE FLOODING.
EXPLORER ENABLES US TO EASILY
VISUALIZE CHANGE AND COMPARE AND
SEE THE CHANGE AS IT HAPPENS
AROUND THE PLANET.  THERE ARE
LIMITS.  PLANET AT THE PRESENT
TIME IS LIMITED IN ZOOM OUTSIDE
THE U.S. AND THE IMAGERY IS
AVAILABLE ON OUR BROWSE ER FOR
PERSONAL AND NONCOMMERCIAL USE.
WE ENCOURAGE COMMERCIAL USE, OF
COURSE, BUT FOR THAT YOU HAVE
TO SIGN UP FOR A PAID ACCOUNT.
AND THEN YOU CAN DOWNLOAD OUR
FULL IMAGERY AND     AND AT FULL
RESOLUTION.
NOW, THERE ARE ZILLIONS OF USE
CASES OF THIS DATA, WHICH IS WHY
WE'VE CREATED AN OPENAPI TO
BUILD APPLICATIONS ON TOP OF IT.
HERE'S A FEW EXAMPLES.
IMAGINE ON A COMMERCIAL SIDE
SIDE, YOU CAN COUNT SHIPS INTO
AND OUT OF PORTS.  IN THIS CASE,
SHIPS AND INTO OUT OF THE PORT
OF SYDNEY.  YOU CAN TRACK
DeFOREST         DEFORESTATION
AND EVEN MEASURE CARBON STOCKS
HERE IN THIS CASE IN BOLIVIA.
EARLIER THIS WEEK OUR PARTNERS,
DESCARTES LAB, RELEASED
GEOVISUAL SEARCH.  HERE A USER
HIGHLIGHTS A FEATURE AND THEN IT
FINDS THOSE FEATURES CARROT
A.  SOLAR ARRAYS IN THE WHOLE
OF CHINA.  IT'S PRETTY FRIGGIN'
COOL.
[ APPLAUSE ]
OUR PARTNERS AND DEVELOPERS ARE
BUILDING APPS ON OUR GEOSPATIAL
DATA AND WE WANT TO GROW THIS
COMMUNITY WHICH IS WHY I'M HERE
TODAY, TO INVITE YOU TO COME AND
JOIN OUR GLOBAL COMMUNITY OF
DEVELOPERS.
WITH PLANET EXPLORER BETA
RUNNING ON GOOGLE CLOUD, PLANET
IS NOW DELIVERING POWERFUL
INSIGHTS ABOUT OUR CHANGING
PLANET MADE AVAILABLE ON LINE AT
YOUR FINGERTIPS.
THE GOAL OF THIS IS TO ENABLE
USERS TO BROWSE OUR IMAGERY AND
EXPLORE HOW IT CAN HELP THEIR
NEEDS.  WE HOPE THAT IT WILL
LEAD TO MORE COMMERCIAL
PARTNERSHIPS
PARTNERSHIPS, MORE BENEFITS ON
THE HUMANITARIAN SIDE.
YOU'VE BEEN USED TO STATIC MAPS
AND PLANET EXPLORER, YOU NOW GET
THE REAL VIEW, WHICH IS A
CONSTANTLY CHANGING PLANET.
PLANET HAS ADDED THE TIME AXIS
TO MAPS AND ANYONE CAN COME TO
PLANET.COM TODAY TO VIEW THAT
IMAGERY.  WE INVITE YOU TO COME
AND EXPLORE WITH US.  THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
[ APPLAUSE ]
AND NOW I'M INTRODUCING WOMEN
FROM ODEN TECHNOLOGIES
WIL
WILLEM WHO IS        FROM
ODEN TECHNOLOGIES WHO IS GOING
TO JOIN US ON STAGE.
[ APPLAUSE ]
Willem Sunblad: HI.  MY NAME IS
SUNBLAD.  I'M COFOUNDER AND CEO
OF ODEN TECHNOLOGIES
TECHNOLOGIES.  I'M HERE TO TALK
ABOUT THE MOST IMPORTANT SECTOR
IN THE U.S. ECONOMY.
MANUFACTURING.  IN 2015, GROSS
OUTPUT OF U.S. FACTORIES WAS
$6.2 TRILLION OR 36% OF GDP.
IT'S EASY TO FORGET THAT THE CAR
YOU DRIVE, BE IT A VOLVO, FORD,
TESLA, IS NOT JUST BUILT BY
VOLUME SARAH, FORD AND TESLA
TESLA.  IT'S MADE UP OF
SOME 30,000 COMPONENTS COMING
FROM A COMPLEX NETWORK OF
MANUFACTURING SUPPLIERS.  THESE
MANUFACTURERS, THEY MAKE
EVERYTHING THAT WE TAKE FOR
GRANTED IN OUR DAILY LIVES.  BUT
THEY HAVE NOT SEEN THE BENEFITS
OF THE TECHNOLOGICAL
ADVANCEMENTS THAT HAVE HAPPENED
IN THE COMPUTER INDUSTRY AND OUR
CONSUMER LIVES IN THE PAST 15,
20 YEARS.
TAKE THE U.S. PLASTICS INDUSTRY
AS AN EXAMPLE.  16,000
FACTORIES, OUTPUT OF ABOUT $370
BILLION, BUT MOST OF THE DATA
THEY COLLECT AND ANALYZE TO
CONTINUOUSLY IMPROVE THEIR
PRODUCTION IS DONE WITH
CLIPBOARDS AND TIMERS, PEN AND
PAPER.  NOW, I'M NOT SAYING THAT
THERE ISN'T INDUSTRIAL
TECHNOLOGY, BUT IT HASN'T BEEN
ACCESSIBLE TO THE WIDER AUDIENCE
.
IT'S ONLY BEEN ACCESSIBLE TO THE
1% OF MANUFACTURERS.  MOST OF
THE HARDWARE IS BUILT ON
PROGRAMMABLE LOGIC CONTROLLERS.
ALMOST ALL SOFTWARE IS HOSTED
LOCALLY.  THE DESIGN OF IT LOOKS
LIKE IT'S FROM THE '90s, AT
BEST, '80s IF YOU'RE LESS LUCKY,
AND IT'S ALWAYS BEEN EXTREMELY
EXPENSIVE.
AND IT CAN TAKE MONTHS TO YEARS
TO IMPLEMENT, EVEN.
BUT IT DOESN'T HAVE TO BE THAT
WAY ANYMORE.  THROUGH UBIQUITY
OF NETWORKS, DRASTIC DECREASE IN
COST OF ELECTRONICS AND CLOUD
COMPUTING, COUPLED WITH THE
TREMENDOUS GROWTH IN POWER AND
TOOLS THAT ARE AVAILABLE
AVAILABLE, SUPERIOR
TECHNOLOGY IS NOW ACCESSIBLE BY
MANUFACTURERS LARGE AND SMALL IN
ALL VERTICALS.  WE FOUNDED ODEN
WITH A CORE MISSION:  TO
EMPOWER MANUFACTURERS WITH DATA
AND TOOLS SO THEY CAN ELIMINATE
WASTE IN THEIR PRODUCTION,
DECREASE RATES, DECREASE MACHINE
FAILURES AND UNPLANNED DOWNTIME
, UNDERSTAND THEIR SETTINGS AND
MINIMIZE THEIR MATERIAL
CONDUCTIONS THAT EVERY
MANUFACTURER CAN MAKE THE MOST
OF THEIR CAPACITY AND MAKE
AWESOME PRODUCTS FOR US   US.
TO DO THIS, WE BUILT A DEVICE
BASED ON THE RASPBERRY PIE THAT
CAN COMMUNICATE WITH MOST
INDUSTRIAL MACHINERY AND
EXTERNAL SENSORS, TAKE DATA IN
REAL TIME, SEND IT AS TO OUR
CLOUD-BASED ANALYTICS PLATFORM.
THE DATA THAT WE'RE COLLECTING
CAN BE GRANULAR INFORMATION
ABOUT HOW THE MATERIAL IS
BEHAVING THROUGHOUT THE PROCESS,
WHAT'S HAPPENING INSIDE OF THE
MACHINE, BUT ALSO HIGHER LEVEL
METRICS LIKE WHAT'S THE
THROUGHPUT FROM HOUR, PER RPM,
PER HORSEPOWER.  WHAT'S THE
UTILIZATION OF YOUR PRODUCTION
LINES OR YOUR WHOLE FACTORIES.
AND WE DO THIS BUILT AND HOSTED
COMPLETELY ON GOOGLE CLOUD
PLATFORM.  THE MILLIONS AND
MILLIONS IN DATA POINTS THAT WE
COLLECT PER PRODUCTION LINE PER
DAY IS INGESTED WITH PUB/SUB.
OUR REALTIME STREAM PROCESSING
FRAMEWORK WHERE WE CAN DO
COMPLEX TRANSFORMATIONS ON THE
DATA LIVES IN CONTAINER ENGINE.
WE'RE ABOUT TO MOVE THAT TO
DATAFLOW.  STORAGE, BIG     BIG
TABLE.  AND THE MICROSERVICES
THAT SUPPORT OUR PLATFORM ALL
LIVES IN CONTAINER
CONTAINER ENGINE AND THE WEB
APPLICATION ITSELF, COMPUTE
ENGINE.  SO MANUFACTURERS GET
REALTIME STREAM OF ALL THE
IMPORTANT METRICS COMING FROM
THEIR PRODUCTION LINES SO THEY
CAN TAKE BETTER DECISIONS IN
REAL TIME, HIGH-LEVEL-OVER VIEW
OF WHOLE PRODUCTION OF LINES OR
MULTIPLE FACTORIES ON YOUR
UTILIZATION STATE, THERAPEUTIC,
WHAT PRODUCTS YOU'RE MAKING,
COMPLETE TRACEABILITY.  YOU CAN
SEARCH THROUGH PRODUCT, TIME
TIME, EVENTS, SO ENGINEERS AND
EXECS CAN SOLVE PROBLEMS,
QUALITY FAILURES, MACHINE
FAILURES, IN MINUTES INSTEAD OF
WEEKS OR MONTHS.  AND ALSO, OF
COURSE, LABEL AND CLASSIFY THE
DATA IN DIFFERENT STATES SO THEY
CAN SHARE AND COLLABORATE, BUT
ALSO BUILD UP MACHINE LEARNING
MODELS SO WE CAN TAKE THEM EVEN
A STEP FURTHER ON MAKING THINGS
MORE EFFICIENTLY, MAKING THINGS
BETTER.
IN THE SAME WAY THAT WE BUILD
TOOLS AND CAPABILITIES THAT
ALLOW OUR CUSTOMERS, THE MEN AND
WOMEN ON THE FACTORY FLOORS
EVERY DAY, TO BUILD BETTER
PRODUCTS AND RUN THEIR FACTORIES
MORE EFFICIENTLY, GOOGLE CLOUD
BUILDS PRODUCTS AND TOOLS THAT
ALLOW US TO BUILD BETTER
PRODUCTS FASTER AND RUN OUR
OPERATIONS MORE EFFICIENTLY.
WE PROBABLY WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO
FEEL COMFORTABLE SCALING UP TO
THOUSAND AND THOUSANDS OF
FACTORIES WITH TENS OF THOUSANDS
OF MACHINES ALL STREAMING DATA
IF WE DIDN'T KNOW WE HAD THE
INFRASTRUCTURE OF GOOGLE TO
ALLOW US TO DO THAT.
AND WITH THAT SAID, I WANT TO
HAND OVER TO HERMAN FROM
IMPROBABLE AND SAY THANK YOU
YOU.
[ APPLAUSE ]
Herman Narula: HELLO.  IT'S AN
ABSOLUTE PLEASURE TO BE HERE.
SO IF WE WANT TO BUILD MASSIVE
GIGANTIC SIMULATIONS OF VIRTUAL
WORLDS OR COMPLETELY NEW WAYS OF
MODELING CITIES OR CELLS OR
ECONOMIES, HUGE SIMULATIONS THAT
RUN ON THOUSANDS OF COURSE,
IT'S      IT'S A REALLY
CHALLENGE TODAY.  IT'S SOMETHING
THAT PREVIOUSLY HAS ONLY REALLY
BEEN AVAILABLE TO PEOPLE WITH
SUPERCOMPUTERS AND IT GENERALLY
PRESENTS A VERY CHALLENGING
PROGRAMMING MODEL FOR DEVELOPERS
.  YOU'VE GOT TO MANAGE SERVERS
SERVERS, YOU'VE GOT TO
COME UP WITH THE SYNCHRONIZATION
WITH THE INFORMATION, YOU'VE
GOT TO DO SO MANY THINGS BEYOND
JUST BUILDING YOUR APPLICATION.
SO AT IMPROBABLE, WE'VE BUILT A
DISTRIBUTED OPERATING SYSTEM WE
CALLED SPATIALOS THAT RUNS ON
GOOGLE CLOUD AND MAKES IT
POSSIBLE TO BUILD THESE KINDS OF
APPLICATIONS.  EXACTLY THE
TYPES OF VIRTUAL WORLDS AND
MASSIVE SIMULATIONS THAT WE'VE
ALL DREAMED OF BUT PUT INTO THE
HANDS OF DEVELOPERS SO THAT IT
CAN BE ITERATED ON AND BUILT
QUICKLY AND EFFICIENTLY.  AND AT
THE END OF THAT LAST YEAR, WE
ANNOUNCED A MASSIVE INNOVATION
PROGRAM WITH GOGGLE WHICH MAKES
IT ALMOST COMPLETELY FREE FOR
HUNDREDS OF GAME STUDIOS TO
BUILD COMPLETELY NEW
APPLICATIONS ON TOP OF SPATIALOS
, AND BUILDERS FIRST AND IT'S
ONLY BEEN A COUPLE OF MONTHS
THERE'S BEEN AN ENORMOUS NUMBER
OF REALLY COOL PRODUCTS PRODUCED
.  I WANT TO SHOW YOU SOME
EXAMPLES OF SOME OF THOSE.
THESE INCLUDE VIRTUAL WORLDS
LIKE WORLDS ADRIFT.  THERE ARE
2,000 SQUARE KILOMETERS IN SIZE.
WORLDS WITH THEIR OWN
ECOLOGIES, WORLDS WITH MASSIVE
NUMBERS OF PLAYERS SHARING THE
SAME SPACE.  NO MORE SHARDING,
NO MORE SEPARATION.  EXPERIENCES
THAT IN MANY CASES THAT HAVE
BEEN BUILT BY TEAMS OF 3 OR 5
DEVELOPERS AND OUR BETA IS LIVE
AND ACTIVE RIGHT NOW AND WITH
THE COMMUNITY WE'RE CONTINUALLY
IMPROVING AND ADDING TO WHAT
SPATIALOS CAN DO FOR GAMING.
BUT TODAY I'M ACTUALLY HERE TO
TALK TO YOU ABOUT THE NEXT STEP,
THE REALLY BIG SIGNIFICANT AND
IMPORTANT PROBLEMS WHICH IN ONE
MOMENT WE WILL SOON BE ABLE TO
TALK ABOUT.
SLIDE TRANSITION.
THERE WE GO.
SO THINKING ABOUT LARGE-
LARGE-SCALE SIMULATION AS A WAY
OF SOLVING PROBLEMS, A GOOD WAY
TO BEGIN IS TO THINK ABOUT AN
EXAMPLE.  THINK ABOUT THE MOST
IMPORTANT DECISION THAT A
COMPANY OR A GOVERNMENT MAKES,
RIGHT?  LET'S TAKE AN EXAMPLE OF
WHAT THAT COULD LOOK LIKE.
IMAGINE THINKING ABOUT HOW TO
CHANGE A MASSIVE CELLULAR
NETWORK THAT SPANS AN ENTIRE
CITY OR A COUNTRY.  ANY CHANGE
YOU MIGHT THINK OF MAKING,
WHETHER IT'S A MODIFICATION TO
THE INFRASTRUCTURE, A CHANGE TO
A PROTOCOL, OR AN ALTERATION IN
POLICY, IS GOING TO HAVE
MILLIONS OF CASCADING EFFECTS
WHICH ARE INCREDIBLE Y DIFFICULT
TO COMPREHEND OR THINK ABOUT,
AND THE REASON FOR THIS IS THAT
WE'RE DEALING REALLY WITH
EMERGENT SYSTEMS AND THIS IS AN
IDEA I WANT TO PUT ACROSS TODAY.
THE IDEA THAT OUR WORLD, THE
CELLS IN YOUR BODY, OUR
ECONOMIES, THE BIG
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT WE'VE BUILT
TOGETHER, THEY ALL REPRESENT
MILLIONS OF COMPLEX EMERGENT
SYSTEMS, AND IF WE REALLY WANT
TO UNDERSTAND THESE SYSTEMS, WE
HAVE TO GO A LOT FURTHER THAN
JUST USING MACHINE LEARNING OR
PATH DATA.  WE NEED TO LEARN TO
COMPLETELY RECREATE THESE
SYSTEMS IN THEIR ENTIRETY.  I
MEAN, ACTUALLY REPLICATE ING
ENTIRE CITIES ON MASSIVE
SIMULATIONS, BUILDING MODELS OF
THESE NETWORKS THAT HAVE NEVER
BEEN POSSIBLE BEFORE.  THIS IS A
GIGANTIC AND DAUNTING
TECHNOLOGY CHALLENGE.  IT CAN'T
BE SOLVED THROUGH PARALLEL --
LARGE-SCALE PARALLEL SYSTEMS
SYSTEMS.  WE NEED TO
BUILD NEW KINDS OF SEMI-PARALLEL
DISTRIBUTED SYSTEMS THAT CAN
MAKE THIS STUFF WORK.  AND IF WE
REALLY WANT TO CHANGE OUR WORLD
WE NEED DEVELOPERS LIKE YOU TO
BE ABLE TO RUN THESE SYSTEMS IN
REAL TIME, BUILD NEW BUSINESSES
AND BUILD NEW SERVICES THAT RUN
ON TOP OF THIS STUFF AND THAT'S
PRECISELY WHAT WE'VE BEEN DOING
WITH SPATIALOS.  AND I'M PLEASED
TODAY TO ANNOUNCE THAT WE'RE
GOING TO BE OPEN SOURCING MORE
AND MORE CONTENT AND SHOWING
MORE AND MORE FRAMEWORKS OVER
THE COURSE OF THE NEXT SIX
MONTHS THAT ARE GOING TO MAKE IT
MORE POSSIBLE FOR NEW
DEVELOPERS TO ATTACK NEW PROBLEM
DOMAINS.  AND JUST LIKE GOOGLE
WITH THE SPIRIT OF OPEN
DEVELOPMENT AND SHARING CONTENT,
WE INTEND TO DO EVERYTHING WE
CAN TO FOSTER A COMMUNITY WHERE
DEVELOPERS CAN SHARE CODE, SHARE
FRAMEWORKS, SHARE INTEGRATIONS
AND START TO BUILD AND CREATE
NEW BUSINESSES AND SERVICES.  WE
DON'T ALL HAVE TO START FROM
SCRATCH.  WE CAN START TO MAKE
AN ECOSYSTEM TO MAKE THIS STUFF
POSSIBLE.  AND THAT'S WHY WE'VE
CHOSEN TO PARTNER WITH GOOGLE
AND WE TRULY BELIEVE THAT THE
CLOUD IS NOT GOING TO BE A ZERO-
ZERO-SUM GAME AND THE AGE
OF CLOSED SYSTEMS AND TRYING TO
TO, IN EFFECT, HOTHOUSE
DEVELOPERS INTO COMMITTING TO A
CLOSED ECOSYSTEM ARE OVER.  WE
CAN'T SUCCEED UNLESS YOU SUCCEED
AND I THINK GOOGLE RECOGNIZES
THAT AND THAT'S THE GENUINE
REASON WHY I'M HERE TODAY AND
WHY WOVEN CHOSEN TO MAKE THIS
PARTNERSHIP HAM.  WITH SERVICES
RANGE ING FROM MACHINE LEARNING
SIMULATIONS THAT CAN BE ADDED
INTO OUR TECH TO INTEGRATIONS
WITH SERVICES LIKE YouTUBE WHICH
WE'LL BE TALKING MORE ABOUT
THIS YEAR THAT ARE GOING TO MAKE
OUR TECHNOLOGY EVEN MORE
FUNCTIONAL AND EVEN MORE USEFUL
TO YOU.  SO I'VE TALKED A LOT
ABOUT WHAT'S POSSIBLE BUT I
HAVEN'T SHOWN YOU ANYTHING
REALLY COOL YET.
SO I WANT TO SHOW YOU SOMETHING
THAT WE BUILT IN CONJUNCTION
WITH THE U.K. GOVERNMENT.  IT'S
BEEN PRETTY SECRET UNTIL JUST
BASICALLY THIS WEEK.  AND I'M
FINALLY ABLE TO SHOW IT TO YOU.
THIS IS THE LARGEST SIMULATION
OF ITS KIND EVER CREATED.  THIS
IS A COMPLETE SIMULATION OF AN
ENTIRE U.K. CITY.  IT'S TELCO
NETWORK, ITS POWER GRID, ITS
TRANSPORT NETWORK, ITS SEWAGE
SYSTEMS, ITS HOUSING
DEMOGRAPHICS, EVEN THE WAY IN
WHICH PEOPLE MOVE AROUND AND
INTERACT WITH THE CITY.  WE'RE
GOING TO BE OPEN SOURCING SOME
OF THIS CONTENT LATER THIS YEAR.
THIS RUNS ON THOUSANDS OF
CORES AND IT'S ABLE TO RUN IN
REAL TIME USING UNITY FOR
VISUALIZATION AND INTERACTION
WITH THE SIMULATION.  THIS IS
ALREADY STARTED TO TRANSFORM THE
WAYS WE LOOK AT CASCADING
FAILURE IN EMERGENT SYSTEMS.
CHANGE HOW WE DO INFRASTRUCTURE
PLANNING, CHANGE HOW WE THINK
ABOUT RUNNING SERVICES, AND MY
CONTENTION TO YOU TODAY IS THAT
THIS IS THE FUTURE FOR HOW WE'RE
GOING TO LOOK AT HOW ALL THE
SYSTEMS IN OUR WORLD OPERATE.
NOT JUST LOOKING AT PAST DATA
BUT RECREATING THEM, RETHINKING
HOW WE CAN MAKE THIS WHAT IF
DECISIONS.  THERE'S EVEN
COMPANIES THAT ARE BEGINNING TO
USE SPATIAL TO RUN SYSTEMS OF
AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES, BEING ABLE
TO MANAGE THEM AS FLEETS.
SO I WANT TO LEAVE YOU WITH AN
IDEA.  THIS THING HERE, AI,
GOOGLE TALKS ABOUT IT ALL THE
TIME.  YOU CAN'T GO ON
TECHCRUNCH WITHOUT SEEING AN AI
ARTICLE.  BUT THIS IDEA, R
ECREATING REALITY, BUILDING
REALITY SCALE SIMULATIONS AND
SERVICES, IS JUST AS IMPORTANT,
AND I BELIEVE IT'S GOING TO
UNDERPIN HOW OUR WORLD IS GOING
TO TRANSFORM, WHETHER IT'S S
IMULATIONS OF TUMORS IN CELLS
THAT CAN HELP US UNDERSTAND
DISEASE OR MODELS OF
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT CAN HELP US
SAVE MONEY AND MAKE BETTER
CHOICES.
SO WITH YOUR HELP AND THE
ABILITY TO BUILD AN OPEN
COMMUNITY ON OUR TECHNOLOGY, WE
HOPE TO KICKSTART THIS.  IF
YOU'RE EXCITED PLEASE CHECK OUT
WHAT WE HAVE ON LINE.  YOU CAN
DOWNLOAD OUR SDK RIGHT NOW AND
GET STARTED MAKING GAMES.  THANK
YOU.  WILL.
[ APPLAUSE ]
Alison Wagonfeld:
HI.  LET'S GIVE A ROUND OF
APPLAUSE TO WILL, WILLEM, AND
HER MAN WHO ARE DOING SUCH GREAT
WORK ON THE CLOUD.
[ APPLAUSE ]
IF YOU WERE HERE ON WEDNESDAY,
YOU PROBABLY HEARD ONE OF OUR
MANY EXCITING ANNOUNCEMENTS,
THAT WE AT GOOGLE HAVE ACQUIRED
KAGGLE.  SO I'M THRILLED TO BE
ABLE TO INVITE THE CEO ON STAGE
WITH US NOW TO SHARE A FEW
THOUGHTS ABOUT WHAT THAT MEANS.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN WELCOMING
ANTHONY GOLDBLOOM.
[ APPLAUSE ]
Alison Wagonfeld: HEY, ANTHONY.
THANK YOU.
SO, ANTHONY, WHEN WE FIRST MET A
COUPLE OF YEARS AGO WE TALKED
ABOUT KAGGLE AS BEING THIS GREAT
PLACE FOR MACHINE LEARNING
COMPETITION.  AND THEN WHEN WE
CONNECTED MORE RECENTLY, I GOT
TO LEARN ABOUT SOME OF THE GREAT
NEW INNOVATIONS AND WHERE THE
COMPANY IS GOING.  CAN YOU SHARE
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE
EVOLUTION OF KAGGLE?
Anthony Goldbloom: , YEAH, SURE.
ALISON, AS YOU SAID, KAGGLE
STARTED OUT RUNNING MILLION
COMPETITIONS.  STILL, I SUSPECT
THAT'S THE THING WE'RE MOST
WELL-KNOWN FOR.  WE WANT TO BE
THE PLACE WHERE DATA SCIENTISTS
DO ALL OF THEIR DATA SCIENCE.
SO IN AUGUST LAST YEAR WE
LAUNCHED AN OPEN DATA PLATFORM.
SO THIS IS A PLACE -- WE HAVE A
VERY LARGE COMMUNITY.  AND THIS
IS A PLACE WHERE THEY CAN SHARE
AND COLLABORATE ON OPEN DATAS.
SO PEOPLE IN OUR COMMUNITY WILL
PUBLISH DATASETS THROUGH THIS
PLATFORM.  WE HAVE EVERYTHING
FROM VERY GRANULAR REAL ESTATE
DATASETS FROM AROUND THE U.S.
THROUGH TO -- I THINK WE HAVE
DATASETS ON ALL CONTEST ANTS FOR
THE FIRST IT 1 SEASONS OF "THE
BACHELORETTE."  IT TURNS OUT OUR
USERS HAVE ECLECTIC TASTE.  WE
HAVE LAUNCHED KAGGLE KERNELS,
THIS ALLOWS DATA SCIENTISTS TO
TRAIN MODELS USING PYTHON AND
SHARE THEM IN AN EASY
REPRODUCIBLE WAY.  IF YOU WANTED
TO PREDICT WHO'S GOING TO WIN
SEASON 22 OF THE BACHELORETTE,
RATHER THAN START WITH A
BLINKING CURSOR, YOU CAN SEE
WHAT OTHERS IN OUR COMMUNITY
HAVE ALREADY DONE.
Alison Wagonfeld: THAT'S SO
GREAT.  I LOVE HOW KERNELS ARE
REALLY A GREAT EVOLUTION OF
KAGGLE.  I'M EXCITED TO SEE HOW
THE COMMUNITY WILL NOW ENGAGE
WITH THAT.
I KNOW ALL OF US AT GOOGLE ARE
VERY EXCITED TO HAVE YOU AS PART
OF OUR TEAM.  AND I'M
INTERESTED TO HEAR FROM YOU
ABOUT WHAT IT MEANS TO KAGGLE TO
BE PART OF GOOGLE.
Anthony Goldbloom: ABSOLUTELY .
I THINK THIS IS GOING TO BE
HUGE FOR OUR COMMUNITY.  SO IF
YOU THINK ABOUT MACHINE
LEARNING, HISTORICALLY MACHINE
LEARNING HAS -- FIRST OF ALL, WE
HAVE A VERY LARGE COMMUNITY.
IT'S ABOUT 850,000.  THEY SHARE
LOTS OF DATASETS AND LOTS OF
KAGGLE KERNELS, LOTS OF CODE
WITHIN KAGGLE.  IF YOU LOOK
WHERE MACHINE LEARNING WAS A FEW
YEARS AGO WITH DATA SCIENCE, IT
WAS MOSTLY TRAINING RANDOM
FORESTS AND REGRESSION WHICH YOU
CAN DO ON A SINGLE MACHINE.
MACHINE LEARNING HAS EVOLVED.
IT'S FAR MORE SOPHISTICATED NOW
AND DO MORE POWERFUL THINGS.  IN
JOINING WITH GOOGLE, WE GIVE
OUR COMMUNITY ACCESS TO THE
WORLD'S MOST ADVANCED MACHINE
LEARNING CLOUD.  SO WE'RE GOING
TO ENABLE FAR, FAR, FAR MORE OUR
COMMUNITY TO DO FAR MORE
POWERFUL THINGS.  I THINK IT'S
GOING TO BE A VERY EXCITING
JOURNEY WITH YOU GUYS.
Alison Wagonfeld: GREAT.  THANK
YOU SO MUCH.  I'M REALLY LOOKING
FORWARD TO WORKING TOGETHER.
Anthony Goldbloom: THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
Alison Wagonfeld: THANK YOU.
[ APPLAUSE ]
SO WE BELIEVE THAT COMPETITION
INSPIRES CREATIVITY.  AND IN
THAT SPIRIT, I HAVE ONE FINAL
ANNOUNCEMENT TO MAKE HERE AT
GOOGLE CLOUD NEXT.
WE ARE ANNOUNCING A MACHINE
LEARNING START-UP COMPETITION SO
THAT WE CAN WORK WITH ALL OF
YOU TO THINK ABOUT HOW WE CAN
CONTINUE TO GROW AND BUILD AND
CREATE GREAT COMPANIES.
SO WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?  WELL,
HERE IS THE ENTRY CRITERIA.
THIS COMPETITION IS OPEN TO
EARLY-STAGE START-UPS.  AS THE
NAME WOULD SUGGEST, ALL
IMPLEMENTING MACHINE LEARNING
BUT NOT JUST GOOGLE CLOUD'S
MACHINE LEARNING BUT ANY MACHINE
LEARNING IN OUR SPIRIT OF
OPENNESS.
AND, FINALLY, THIS IS OPEN TO
ANY VERTICAL FROM ENERGY, TO
RETAIL, TO HEALTHCARE.  WE ARE
EXCITED TO WORK WITH START-UPS
OF ALL KINDS AND IN ALL SPACES,
THINKING ABOUT HOW TO LEVERAGE
MACHINE LEARNING TO BUILD GREAT
THINGS.
AND AS FOR THE PRIZES, THERE'S
TWO SETS OF PRIZES.  THE FIRST
FROM GOOGLE.  SO GOOGLE IS GOING
TO BE OFFERING UP TO $1 MILLION
OF GCP CREDITS.  ACTUALLY NOT
UP TO 1 MILLION -- $1 MILLION OF
GCP CREDITS TO THE WINNER.
IN ADDITION, WE ARE OFFERING THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK ONE-ON-ONE
WITH OUR GOOGLE ENGINEERS TO
CONTINUE TO BUILD AND TUNE YOUR
MODELS.  AND, OF COURSE, G SUITE
SEATS.  BUT BEYOND GOOGLE'S
PRIZES, I'M EXCITED THAT WE HAVE
PRIZES FROM ANOTHER COMMUNITY.
AND THAT'S VC PARTNERS.  WE
TEAMED UP WITH SEVEN GREAT
FIRMS, SEQUOIA, KPCB, GV, DATA
COLLECTIVE, EMERGE CAPITAL
GREYLOCK PARTNERS WHO ARE
SUPPORTING THIS COMPETITION.
AND HOT OFF THE PRESS, TWO OF
THESE FIRMS HAVE NOW STEPPED
FORWARD, DATA COLLECTIVE AND
EMERGENCE CAPITAL TO OFFER
INVESTMENTS TO THE WINNER SO
EACH OF THESE FIRMS IS PLANNING
TO OFFER $500,000 TO THE WINNER
OF THIS START-UP COMPETITION.
SO NOW I'M PLEASED TO WELCOME ON
STAGE PARTNERS FROM EACH OF
THESE TERMS, SANTI SUBOTOVSKY
FROM EMERGENCE CAPITAL AND MATT
OCKO FROM DATA COLLECTIVE WHO
ARE GOING TO SHARE A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT WHAT THEY ARE LOOKING FOR
WHEN THEY THINK ABOUT MACHINE
LEARNING START-UPS.  PLEASE JOIN
ME IN WELCOMING SANTI AND MATT.
[ APPLAUSE ]
Alison Wagonfeld: MATT, GREAT TO
HAVE YOU HERE.  HEY, SANTI.
FIRST OF ALL, THANK YOU FOR
TEAMING UP WITH US.  I'M REALLY
EXCITED ABOUT THIS COMPETITION.
AS YOU KNOW, I HAVE A
BACKGROUND IN VENTURE AND I LOVE
WORKING WITH EARLY-STAGE
COMPANIES.  ALL OF US DO AT
GOOGLE.
AND SO I WANTED TO GIVE EACH OF
YOU AN OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE WHAT
YOU'RE EXCITED ABOUT AND WHAT
YOU'RE LOOKING FOR IN THESE
EARLY-STAGE ML COMPANIES.  MATT,
LET'S START WITH YOU.
Matt Ocko: OKAY.  SO TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT WE'RE LOOKING
FOR, FIRST YOU HAVE TO
UNDERSTAND A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
OUR FIRM.  VCs ARE FOND OF
SAYING WE MANAGE $10 BILLION OR,
YOU KNOW, WE WERE THE FIRST
INVESTORS IN GENENTECH OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT.  I WILL
SIMPLIFY IT.
WE HAVE A DOUBLE HANDFUL OF
PARTNERS WHO INVEST IN US.  OUR
LIMITED PARTNERS AGGREGATE ABOUT
A TRILL DOLLARS OF LIQUID
CAPITAL AND THEY ENTRUST US WITH
A REASONABLE PERCENTAGE OF THAT
TO BACK AMBITIOUS IDEAS FROM
FOLKS LIKE YOURSELF.
WHAT WE'RE LOOKING FOR BROADLY
ARE PEOPLE ATTEMPTING THE
IMPOSSIBLE.  WE'RE NOT
INTERESTED IN APPS.  WE'RE NOT
INTERESTED IN WIDGETS.  WE
INVEST IN WHAT'S CLOAKALLY
COLLOQUIALLY KNOWN AS DEEP
TECH.  I GREW UP IN A DARK,
POLLUTED TIME, NOT TODAY, THE
1970s, WHEN A ONE MEGAHERTZ
PROCESSOR WAS A THING OF WONDER
AND 16K OF RAM WAS A BLESSING.
I WATCHED MY GREAT UNCLE SPEND A
YEAR AT STANFORD SEQUENCING A
SINGLE GENE.  WHEN THE SPACE
SHUTTLE LAUNCHED, EVEN WHEN IT
ROLLED OUT OF THE HANGAR, WITH
THE WORD "ENTERPRISE" ON IT, MY
NERD'S HEART LEPT WITH JOY.
THESE WERE CRUDE, PAINFUL THINGS
RELATIVE TO WHAT WE HAVE IN
HAND NOW.  AND THANKS TO MOHR'S
LAW, THANKS TO SELF-REINFORCING
VIRTUOUS CYCLE OF ALGORITHMIC
INNOVATION, WE HAVE THE ABILITY
TO EXPONENTIALLY GO BEYOND WHAT
I GREW UP WITH, WHAT WAS TRUE IN
THE PAST.
WE'RE LOOKING FOR PEOPLE WHO
APPLY DEEP COMPUTE, DEEP TECH,
NOVEL ALGORITHMS, PROPRIETARY
DATA TO ATTACK THE IMPOSSIBLE IN
GIGANTIC INDUSTRIES AND CREATE
MULTIDECADE MONOPOLIES.  THAT'S
HOW WE MAKE OUR MONEY, BUT
THAT'S ALSO -- AS HACKNEYED AS
THIS PHRASE MAY BE, MAKE THE
WORLD A BETTER PLACE.  AND WHAT
WE'RE LOOKING FOR IS PEOPLE WHO
WILL ACCEPT THAT CHALLENGE, WILL
RISE TO THAT CHALLENGE, AND
MAKE SOMETHING GREAT.
Alison Wagonfeld: THANK YOU SO
MUCH, MATT.
[ APPLAUSE ]
Santi Subotovsky: SO, THANK YOU,
ALISON.  WE ARE SUPER THRILLED
TO BE PARTNERING WITH GOOGLE AND
WITH DATA COLLECTIVE ON THIS
COMPETITION.  JUST TO GIVE YOU A
LITTLE BIT OF BACKGROUND, AT
EMERGENCE, WE HAVE BEEN
INVESTING IN ENTERPRISE CLOUD
COMPANIES FOR THE LAST 15 YEARS.
AND AS EARLY BELIEVERS, WE SAW
THIS MASSIVE TECTONIC SHIFT
FROM CLIENT SERVER TO THE CLOUD.
NOW WE BELIEVE WE'RE STARTING
TO SEE ANOTHER MASSIVE CHANGE
WITH ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE OF
MACHINE LEARNING.
AND IT'S GOING TO HAPPEN IN THE
NEXT TEN YEARS.  WE BELIEVE IT'S
GOING TO EFFECT EVERY PROCESS
WITHIN THE ENTERPRISES.  AND THE
WAY WE THINK ABOUT THIS IS MOST
ENTERPRISE CLOUD COMPANIES ARE
TAKING WORKFLOWS AND MOVING THEM
TO THE CLOUD.  WITH MACHINE
LEARNING AND OUR ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE, WE FEEL THAT WE
CAN START BENDING THOSE
WORKFLOWS AND CLOSING THE LOOP
AND CREATING WHAT WE CALL A
COACHING CLOUD, WHERE YOU CAN
CLOSE THE LOOP AND AUTOMATICALLY
THE SYSTEM GETS BETTER AND
BETTER EVERY TIME A NEW WORKFLOW
IS BEING PROCESSED.
WE'RE EXCITED BECAUSE WE BELIEVE
THAT THAT HAS THE POTENTIAL OF
DISRUPTING THE NOW INCUMBENTS OF
THE CLOUD IF THEY DON'T MOVE
FAST ENOUGH.  THAT'S WHAT WE
LIKE TO DO.  I MEAN, WE LIKE TO
BUILD GREAT THINGS WITH OUR
ENTREPRENEURS.
AND IN TERMS OF THE AREAS WE SEE
THIS HAPPENING, JUST THINK
ABOUT WHETHER THERE'S A TON OF
DATA AND WHERE THERE'S HUMAN
INTERACTION.  THINK OF, I DON'T
KNOW, LOW-HANGING FRUIT, CRM,
CUSTOMER SUCCESS, MARKETING, A
TON OF DATA AND A LOT OF
REPEATED PROCESSES THAT SHOULD
BE GETTING BETTER AND BETTER
AUTOMATICALLY AS YOU CLOSE THIS
LOOP.
AND WE'RE ALSO EXCITED BECAUSE
WE DID SOMETHING SIMILAR TEN
YEARS AGO.  AND THE WINNER OF
THAT COMPETITION WAS A COMPANY
CALLED SERVICE MAX THAT RECENTLY
GOT ACQUIRED BY GE FOR ABOUT A
BILLION DOLLARS.  SO WE EXPECT
TO REPLICATE THAT OUTCOME WITH
GOOGLE AND DATA COLLECTIVE IN AN
EVEN MORE MEANINGFUL WAY.
Alison Wagonfeld: THAT SOUNDS
GREAT BECAUSE WE WERE THINKING
ABOUT INVESTING BETWEEN ALL OF
US $2 MILLION IN THE WINNER AND
A BILLION DOLLAR OUTCOME IS
SOMETHING I'M SURE EVERYBODY
WOULD LOVE TO SEE.  SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
Santi Subotovsky: THANK YOU.
Matt Ocko: PLEASURE.
[ APPLAUSE ]
Alison Wagonfeld: AND THIS
BRINGS US TO THE END OF OUR
KEYNOTE FOR GOOGLE CLOUD NEXT.
IT HAS BEEN AN INCREDIBLE THREE
DAYS.  ON WEDNESDAY, WE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HEAR FROM GOOGLE
LEADERS AND ENTERPRISE COMPANIES
THAT ARE TRULY ENGAGING AND
BUILDING WITH GOOGLE CLOUD AND
USING G SUITE TO REALLY
COLLABORATE IN THEIR
ORGANIZATIONS.
YESTERDAY WE SAW -- GOT TO
LISTEN TO OVER TWO DOZEN PRODUCT
ANNOUNCEMENTS AND EXCITING
GROWTH AREAS IN OUR PRODUCTS AND
SAW DEMOS OF THOSE.  IF YOU
DIDN'T CATCH THEM LIVE, BE SURE
TO LOOK AT THEM ON YOUTUBE.
AND THEN TODAY I REALLY ENJOYED
HEARING ABOUT THE OPEN CLOUD
COMMUNITY AND HOW START-UPS ARE
BUILDING WITH GOOGLE CLOUD.
I WANT TO GIVE YOU A MOMENT AND
A LITTLE INFORMATION ABOUT SOME
FUTURE EVENTS COMING UP.  SO
WE'RE GOING TO BE GOING GLOBAL
WITH GOOGLE CLOUD NEXT, LONDON
AND TOKYO.  AND THEN PLEASE SAVE
THE DATE FOR 2018 BACK HERE
IN SAN FRANCISCO.
AND, FINALLY, I WANT TO THANK
ALL OF US WHO        YOU WHO
HAVE BEEN HERE AND ENGAGING WITH
US OVER THE PAST THREE DAYS.
AND A BIG THANK YOU TO ALL THE
GOOGLERS THAT HAVE HELPED BRING
THIS ALL.  ON BEHALF OF EVERYONE
AT GOOGLE CLOUD WHAT REALLY
INSPIRES US AND MOTIVATES US IS
BRINGING GREAT TECHNOLOGY TO
MARKET AND THINKING ABOUT WHAT
ALL OF US CAN BUILD TOGETHER.
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR BEING
PART OF THIS GREAT CONFERENCE
AND I'D LIKE TO CLOSE WITH A
PHOTO MONTAGE OF SOME OF MY
FAVORITE MOMENTS OVER THE LAST